[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the playoffs are here the playoffs are
here we are all excited uh we all got
our Best Bets we're gonna go around the
horn Bryson got a very very interesting
bet we're going to save him for last
I'll go first guys I'll I'll just start
this guys this off easy you guys see the
Jersey I'm rocking y'all know I'm
rocking 49ers money line that is my
favorite bet I got other bets I got
other beds don't laugh at me Michael I
got other bets okay but that's my
favorite one bro that's my favorite Sam
so well great first of all it's great to
be here with everyone you know in person
the studio is amazing I am trying to
figure out the lay of the land do I
stare at that camera where I look Ryan
I'll I'll ask you I'll figure it out
later right there right there all right
um I'm thinking big picture
so yes I could take the Niners to win
today I could take the Niner spread I'm
taking the Niners to win the Super Bowl
and I'm going to put myself on the path
for the next month to just ride along
with Brock Purdy and the boys CMC Devo
everyone so I'm just taking Niners from
the Super Bowl and that that's the only
thing that's on my mind today there it
is Niners to win the Super Bowl Q
Anderson too
disagrees with you Seahawks winning No
Cap okay okay
has anyone comment on the Ed Sheeran hat
because that's like that is the most
that's the most important thing uh no
okay
all right Ritter if anyone knows
anything about my past I was a weather
boy at one point and if anyone knows
anything about the game today it could
be a little crummy and it rained all day
so I'm being a square and I'm taking the
under that's going to be my big bet
today uh 42 and a half Michael Ritter is
rocking with the under in the rain in
the rain it is raining out there in
California uh
is it still a man of the people it's the
weather is not as bad as we thought it
was gonna I can get there
I thought I heard the thought I heard
the man amen of the people the people
want to know best bet I mean what's your
record on this show
his record of the season is like 33 and
35. we talk about the best bet record
saves me being a hater again like every
week uh yeah I think the king of the
king of the best bet is probably the
better than the king of the rats
don't do that don't do that best bet
today DK Metcalf over four and a half
receptions I believe I got it at -135
DraftKings uh Gino Smith will be Force
feeding him all day long because the
Seahawks will be trailing and they need
to get it to a playmaker DK Metcalf over
four and a half percent Ryan likes DK
Metcalf my my eyes keep watering I don't
know why maybe it's the right I'm
getting emotional the 49ers about to win
a big game they are about to win a big
game thank you for speaking that into
existence we got my boy Logan in the
back and and unfortunately
should we just skip him we should no no
honestly first of all most of you know
me more formally as bagel and lox or
King of the Rat Collective Ryan's Ryan
is lucky I'm not in the chat today
absolutely just abuse him
we're all here don't get confused by the
CIA Ox tarp I'm a Jets fan but I got a
ride wagon I got a ride with my boy Gino
you know Jets Legend uh we gave up on
him a little bit too early but I'm
hoping he's not riding back today uh
Seahawks plus nine and a half okay
that's like that's bad vibes that is
terrible Vibes that is terrible bugs
bagel and locks that is terrible Vibes
but it's okay we love you still my boy
Vinnie Mick baby if you guys don't know
my man goes viral on Tick Tock every
week it seems like Vinnie Mick man how
we doing back there we're doing good I'm
happy to be here happy to be back yeah
we're back for another watch party and
uh I will have to say Logan let's ride
let's go baby all over Seahawks plus one
and a half I think this is playing into
exactly the final game that Pete Carroll
well it's tough to see that's why
they're in the back
[Laughter]
birds of War we're gonna fly together
but I will say that uh
uh Eli Mitchell over 38 and a half yards
something I'm locking I really like that
he's back he's healthy yeah I like that
there's gonna be again a ground and
pound running game and uh yeah uh we
locked in we're going my man Eli is back
they're going to be running the ball
it's a lot of rain out there in
California
we saved the best for last my man
Bryson's been cooking this one for uh I
don't know how long it's probably been a
week or so but Bryson tell the people
what you've done just help me go ahead
so I spent my entire week deep in
quantitative research
to find my best bet this week and you
know I don't bet big very often people
get it to misconstrue I bet like an
idiot I did not bet big but this in my
opinion is my hammer lock Max whale play
of the year the game total would be odd
minus 110 at our good friends of
DraftKings Sportsbook they're giving me
a discount on something that should be
minus 130 in my opinion here's the
quantitative research it took me about
four or five minutes on flash score
looking at game history yeah
um the the total in Seahawks Niner since
1997 has finished odds 74 of the time
this year both games finished even
three two times in their history before
this season the game tunnel was even
what are you doing why are we hammering
yeah
we're not listening and guess what
happened the third game somebody guessed
it finished odd and here we are in the
third game it's gonna finish odd and
guys at the end of the day man like at
the end of the day you're saying flip a
coin that's what I'm doing here
Bryson the most important part is how
much money are you flipping that coin on
a thousand dollars oh my God all right I
think I just please our audience do not
tell that to the extent like if you want
to put five dollars on it do not do it
he just did no well it's up to you hey
audience
I'm not selling anyone more on anything
else you heard all these losers up here
giving out
at the end of the day I'm confident all
right that's all you need right now
that's true Clear Eyes Full Hearts can't
lose and I got both yeah I I didn't I
didn't like the Vibes at the end of all
that so let's just get to the people uh
we have a parlay Department let's go uh
five legs five legs
already but we need your locks get in
the chat drop some locks and and let's
build it up uh
Dill Dylan Nguyen said 49ers minus three
DK touchdown and a Debo touchdown uh
which one of those three do you guys
like 49ers minus I actually was gonna
push for 49ers money line to be the
first leg but I actually don't hate the
miners the minus three I like it yeah
because and we do minus two and a half I
like 200 here go Ryan not go ahead go
ahead well I don't want to pushing it
down
go ahead minus two and a half my 49ers
minus two and a half
yeah minus 380. oh it's beautiful for a
leg
I like that definitely I got Seahawks
plus 11 and a half at minus 150. I love
that
the odds are great today all right uh do
you want to defend yourself that you
just bought two points to the chat like
yeah we that's what I was I was saying
to Ritter when when Vince and Logan were
talking about how they're on the
Seahawks I am as well but I bought two
points to plus 11 and a half because I
can see this game being 21. yeah
disgusting oh disgusting Behavior I mean
if it if they lose by 11 points you guys
will never hear the end of this one I
promise but if they lose by 12 then you
just like gave away you know extra money
what happened when they win they lose by
12 in the game fiddle is odd then you're
rich and he's poor yeah well no I tail
prices okay good choice you're welcome
yeah I'm a Vibes guy unlike you I'm a
Vibes guy all right so Niners minus two
and a half
first legs do we like that chat thumbs
up thumbs down like that uh we got a
from even total Squad
akr huh even total score in the chat
yeah somebody's coming at Bryce in here
uh I we got a Nick Bosa one sack oh I
got that already a lot of comments about
how Ritter looks and Ritter's looking we
could put that in Ryan if you want thank
you it's like minus two something
one is 280. yeah minus 280 for one sack
yeah oh man for our Niners in a sec for
Nick Bosa Nick Bosa oh okay uh wait do
you know I like that
can we do what are the odds player sacks
minus 280. so it gets us to minus 130 if
we put that in I got to do some quick
research on his sack totals I mean he's
the best he's the defensive player no
he's the best by far uh Leo it is insane
how good he is at Leo Pena Kittle TD I
like kettle TD but I don't know in the
in the weather it's too I don't want to
do it anytime TV I really like it but I
don't know with the weather well we
already have in the cafe a lot of people
are saying 49ers three plus sacks do we
like that over Bosa I kind of like we
can't do team sacks in in New York go
check the odds
what was the team sacks for 49ers uh I
think I don't think we can I don't think
yeah
okay it doesn't have to be posted we
could do something I saw I think the
that same person dropped they did uh
quiet KKR said uh I uke over 30 yards
yeah
but yeah they dropped a ton of plays
that I mean I'm not gonna oh we're not
gonna take your entire same game parlay
someone tweeted this the other day which
I agree with is like the biggest do you
know ball test today is like your
thoughts on brand IU because that guy is
so
let's get a curse that guy's so good
she's so good people do not realize how
good he is and how Dynamic he is and how
like it's not just kiddle McCaffrey and
deboing that offense ayuke is one of the
best receivers going on Rockford he's
making him look like the number one not
gonna lie yeah it's kind of a safety so
what does 30 plus yards yeah yeah what
is it 30. so over 29 and a half yards
would be minus 265 which is better value
than the Nick Bosa OnePlus sack if we
like that I'm down with that I'm down
here with that all right let's do that
so then that would be that would get us
to minus 135.
I'm seeing some like field goals like
Robbie Gold over here we're moving we're
moving minus 135 we're tracking yeah
yeah uh one and a half field goals I
like that Seahawks team total under it's
at 15 and a half yeah that's gonna be uh
that's gonna be a no slow it's too low
yeah what's someone throughout McCaffrey
60 plus
yeah what is that a rush yeah rush just
never know with the reception
you do an all-purpose for him
I don't I don't think you can in the
same game I like n Jansen the lowest you
can go from Capri is 65 plus and what
are the odds there minus 255. in the
elements rookie quarterback you
mentioned Robbie oh don't don't talk
about Brock Purdy like this now this is
my quarterback
rookie quarterback they were gonna be
calling him Joe Montana in 15 minutes so
is he not or is he or is he Izzy or is
he not a rookie quarter but he looks
great he doesn't look like a rookie
quarterback but is he or is he not a
rookie quarterback no he is a rookie
thank you rookie quarterback the
elements yeah
division Robbie go to division arrival
Robbie Gold you mentioned it Sam so my
only concern with that is are there
going to be less field goals because
it's windy
that's my only concern with taking field
goal problems
yeah what's the latest from the
weatherman like what are we Robbie is
like 10 miles per hour on and off like
all day so we got the radar pulled up
right here oh radar down in the Santa
Clara down in the southern the South Bay
uh but yeah we're we're just gonna be
dealing with rain just about all day all
day pretty much it's gonna be on and off
it doesn't look it doesn't look heavy I
I'll get in on the I'll look at a
velocity map and get us a wind report
okay guys what about this whole problem
what about this one Tyler Lockett 45
receiving he will see a few deep balls
it rains in Seattle every day then
somebody backed him up and said uh that
was Jimmy Schultz and then Leo said lock
it is Gino's favorite Target yeah there
is a lot of lots let's let's think about
this though guys because we know Ward's
gonna be on DK yep
the the other Corner that the 49ers have
uh let me air I think that's his last
name 38 he's not that good he's gonna be
lined up unlock it I will say this
Niners defense obviously best in the
league the only place they are week is
the Deep ball yes and if you know if
it's only 50 yards it takes one Tyler
Lockett deep ball to potentially catch
this call me crazy do we like lock it 45
plus better or a lock at four plus
receptions better
I'll say something as well the onion
says real quick Bryson the onion says
locket scores touchdowns we've already
said no no no no
I went to school Kansas State
man absolutely that's bad vibes they got
cooked to basketball today who's
surprised I just don't like bet on
K-State players
lets me know this every week uh the
parlay is not about you okay that's true
yeah
we got to get the next leg you're
leaving me hanging while you're at it
just put games
there it is yeah we do have to get that
yeah we don't have much time A lot of
people are saying yards 42 yards I like
yards mortgages
so that's three legs oh plus 150. here
we are now stop it don't tell me
uh Where Do We Go From Here Leo Pena was
about the 45 plus two Where Do We Go
From Here shout out to you
that's a good point where did we go we
never touched McCaffrey right we didn't
just because we have that already
leveraged we have that with the Boost
yeah Dylan Nguyen that guy's very good
at playing football he is Kenneth Walker
50 plus rushing yards
Walker's interesting
yeah great Russians yeah that's true
that defense is nice
I had nothing to do with the game total
so so it didn't I don't know
what Kenneth Walker rushards is the game
script that I'm projecting is Niners go
up big Seahawks need to throw that's why
I'm cool with locket but Loose by 11.
this is the game total Oddity yeah yeah
buddy oh somebody said I don't I'm just
bringing this up because I'm looking at
the chat somebody said Brock Purdy
over six and a half rushing yards I saw
that too I don't know
in terms of what he's done recently it's
the playoffs
plus rushing yards
let me I'm pulling up pulling up stats
yeah six plus yeah all right what's your
take on that right
I love it there's the most recent games
seven yards minus three six yards minus
two three yards minus one he's literally
not hit it once yeah that's small
besides last week yeah so that's gonna
be a pastoronian cheese but it's the
playoff s it's different a different
Playbook they're going to have to make
play but you got Bryson I like Geno
Smith passing attempts over yeah like I
do that yeah what's the what's the what
is it 32
right so I think you'd have 30 plus
probably right you know Smith passing
attempts do the others did you get that
from the chat
dude I'm where my phone's at
Bros
you guys should take the library strick
dropped in the chat I saw it somewhere
in there I think we should take
McCaffrey
like his whatever his lowest rushing
yard is like it's just a nice nice leg
we did drop a uh
to get some legs and I will give you
credit uh buckets on Twitter
bucket said it on Twitter yeah you
wouldn't know about Twitter but I also
like go I think McCaffrey should be in
there but also like don't want to be the
one to like say we have to do it and
then it loses and then everyone is going
to be mean to me so yeah that's true you
don't want to be that you don't want to
be that guy the onions came in here and
asked if we can avenge Jordan Mason
in the playoffs
he didn't score he scored he did bro but
in my mind he scored it's two it'll
always be cheaper
he's going to run for 40 yards yeah
I don't know
is 10. I don't know how I added
McCaffrey 65 Plus in here I don't know
if that's what we want to do or if we
like we definitely need two more legs I
also think we should add something
that's plus money in here to Juice It Up
sorry what is McCaffrey's receiving prop
uh okay like what's his lowest receiving
uh 19 and a half there he is block 13
baby somebody said these are 30 and a
half is crazy lowest you can go is 19
and a half and it's minus 500.
what's Debo's receiving that's not a bad
leg instead of the Russian total
instead of the Russian tool or we could
do McCaffrey receptions McCaffrey
receptions the onions just said it over
three and a half that's a little oh
that's a Lickety
that's a Lickety
yeah I would do McCaffrey receptions
what is it it's minus minus 650 but for
three this could be the yeah but this
could be the plus money one that we put
in here because I'll be honest with you
I like five plus I like six plus
receptions
what is five what would five do
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you
know I'm 25. oh that's pretty good okay
so what so read it out loud you'll get
the chats
okay well wait I actually know now we
have 11 minutes
should we be doing McCaffrey receptions
while we also have McCaffrey rushing
yards do we need to figure that out what
do we take out like
if I saw a guy right by strick he said
uh Geno Smith passing attempts over now
you have it I got a fan I got a fan you
have a fan now he does have a boy hey
let's rock with it he's a community
and then whatever [ __ ] Bryson was
yeah Gino the passion steps I like that
see what that does foreign
[Laughter]
five puts us at
Plus 500.
yeah it's pretty that's good we're at 5
25.
Benchmark he said that's the chat
okay all right okay
plus 500. it's in plus 500 now he
doesn't want it what's going on okay
the fives were 10 minutes before this
game starts and The Vibes are already
way up I need the chat I need the chat
thumbs up or thumbs down on this parlay
right now it is San Francisco 49ers
minus two and a half Brandon iuk over 29
and a half receiving yards Tyler Lockett
45 plus receiving yards Christian
McCaffrey five plus reception and Geno
Smith 30 plus passing attempts okay the
only thing I would consider is teasing
down McCaffrey reception here we go
so what you're telling me is that you
guys just didn't listen no you didn't
listen and do what we did yeah
okay no you're trying to switch it up
over there
I'm trying to get this right that's
going to get us down no you're trying to
get us to get rich plus 450. you're
trying to get rich what you're trying to
win I want to get rich too but I want to
win before I get rich no I no we've got
bat-have boy 99 with a bunch of thumbs
up to my original question on this okay
what was the original question original
question with the five plus
you want to do five plus because look at
this it's plus 360. if we tease it down
to four pretty low
I would do if we're okay how about this
if if we're cool with 30 plus for Gino
Plus for McCaffrey what if we bump up
Tyler Lockett like the to the next level
I'm always trying to bump down
I'm trying to win bro all right we got
to make a decision
Niners plus nine and a half
that's a lock if you ask uh
all right we do need to hurry up yeah so
melly's got a program all right we need
to decide to be able to ride with us
we're gonna take a poll unless I'm
watching the show we're gonna take a
poll right now raise your hand if you
want four receptions
that's the room
49ers minus two and a half yeah over 29
and a half receiving yards for Brandon
iuk 45 plus receiving yards for Tyler
Lockett 30 plus passing attempts The
Bryson leg uh for Gino Smith and four
plus prices
I'm feeling good baby Niners baby games
hey I'm feeling good are we all feeling
good about our parlay The Vibes can we
get the Vibes like trending this way
yeah yeah that's awesome I feel good
yeah we all have to come together after
yelling at each other
I have one more thing to bring up one
more thing
offensive first drive oh I like that
score or no score no score I got punched
what's the what what I mean it just
depends on who hits the ball like Niners
what's 25 bucks for me
does everyone know like obviously we
have six months you have 25 dollars
one more time for the people so they
know what we're on we're also going to
have it in the app below the live stream
just read it one more time right we're
giving these people five minutes to tell
this bet I'm just yeah okay 49ers minus
two and a half over 29 and a half
receiving yards for Brandon iuk 45 plus
receiving yards for Tyler Lockett The
Bryson leg 30 plus Geno Smith passing
attempts and four plus Christian Academy
I'm trying to lock it in all right
bucks
not listening but we gotta go around the
horn real quick no Score first drive if
we think they're going to score or no
score I'm going first I'm gonna go uh
score I'm saying no no no no score no
score no score no Ryan uh
which I respect uh yeah
Ryan is trying to bet and while Ryan's
bet everybody here put in some
individual plays for this game everybody
in here our producer wandered around we
got producer Max in my ear now asking me
for me to put money on this for him I
don't have that much money in my
drafting account
so we could see what we are all betting
yes let's go to the spreadsheet while
producer Ryan that's the spreadsheet
those are all our bets for today you
guys take a look at it take a gander
take a hard Gander take a look at it uh
anybody got something that they just
want to mention anybody anybody got
something that they want to mention yeah
you just asked about it Greg I got first
driver's old punt as as one of my five
picks on this game you like minus 130
yep in the monsoon in the monsoon I like
that absolutely improv play here can
everyone pick besides himself who they
think is going to have the best record
up over the board who's got like beside
yourself who's gonna have the best
winning percentage up on them that's a
good that's a great great
I'll say Logan nice I like Logan's place
I want before the game starts for Ritter
to spread some Niners 31-10 I like Sam
okay so the 31 yeah
and I've been working in our DMS for two
plus years now and seeing all you guys
hit these and I want to join in the fun
and I really like the Niners today I
think that they win I think it stays
under that score is below that that
total and I think 31-10 I think it's a
9.65 65-1 and it's odd so Bryce exact
score 31 to 10 Niners Victory 65-1 65-1
but yeah that's that's one of them
revisit this when that's the final score
and then we have yet to mention also uh
Christian McCaffrey anytime
we definitely boosted the Christian
McCaffrey that's a really good deal
that's an amazing yeah it's a really
good yeah I have good news for everyone
um
I use the DK boost and I got our parlay
to plus four six
[Applause]
for producer Max and Bryson I got your
bed into so there you go wow I'm gonna
win no Brian gets 12 bucks no no I
didn't use the boost for you did
something for me in there too it's under
me in there what's that get some I'll
take some too
of the parlay I put it puts them on oh
did you not do it you guys
see it right there whatever for me I'ma
go read some comments and guys let's
just grade some of these comments
there's the Boost twice don't use the
Boost okay
I'm gonna win 100 bucks then
I get that I want to know how much I'm
going to win so I know how much I'm
gonna freak out I think you know throws
the ball away I take a screenshot hold
on you asked for
25.15. dude let's go all right
all right I love how I asked Ryan if I
was gonna win one I couldn't use the
boost for you and I'm winning 115. you
know Ryan gets a lot of flack but he's
doing a lot right now no he is let's I'm
juggling here we go Santa Clara
California where the Golden Gate Bridge
is the world famous
Ritter I took an unusual weather class
one time in college yeah
I'm curious 59 or 79 humidity how's that
going to impact the game today
are usually the more human it is the
better the ball Flies who do we talk to
about being able to hear the game audio
we can just do the commentary
impersonation we got a little side who
is commentating the game Joe Davis and
John Daryl moose John Davis and John
87 says if Seahawks win I'm on the show
next week invite the doctor sounds good
you also be out you can be on the show
next week that we don't have let's see
okay the doctor will not be on the show
next week I'm so sorry they're not I I
feel good about the parlay I feel like
we ended anyways I'm I'm super happy
because I got it boosted to something so
yeah we got your chalk and he didn't say
anything the game is starting right now
he's nice he just left oh we got the
part right we got the player tell me
that guys I feel so good about possible
yeah
I feel great I feel even better about
plus 11 and a half well I I feel great
that we didn't have to buy two
additional points
everyone knows this is the the Seahawks
sort of betting right definitely right
here there's a little partition Niners
right there and then I'm all in the
morning game total odd over there we're
good we are locked and loaded I'm
feeling good I got some parlay feeling
good about our my beds
what did we come I was too busy placing
bets for you know half the office here
what did we decide on who is going to
have the best record me me only red or
vote it's unfair to you guys that I'm
gonna have the best record because I
have one bet that's gonna win like I
really liked Sam's play though did
anyone not say themselves I completely
blacked out during that that
conversation I didn't vote yeah I didn't
I didn't cast
oh let me let me pull up the spreadsheet
and I'll give you an answer on okay
uh Dylan Nguyen said rat tell Ritter to
um
on cross's legs or this BET's gonna lose
oh man ours is a comfortable way to say
yeah no I'll never be on the side I'm a
fan of the car like this I wish can you
guys zoom in show off my calves
my cows are nice I don't know if you
guys whoever's whoever look at my shoes
are still on
um this feels weird Community Legend
bath Ave boy place like parlays so let's
go Good Vibes Good Vibes
I also the Calm before the storm after I
win this bet I'm gonna buy a lazy boy
recliner for next time I'm live watching
nice
kind of nervous you you uh recliners
when you're sweating bets are you you
have to be standing up
I stand up behind the couch yeah like
definitely like at the end yes like 100
like anybody want to bet on who's
getting the ball first
before the game starts let's go around
around the horn yep everyone's Super
Bowl pick match up and who's winning
Greg first Niners
Chiefs
49ers win
go on niners bills Niners win
uh I am going Niners Bengals
Niners they're losing Bengals are losing
tomorrow yeah we can unpack that later
uh Cowboys Bengals uh Cowboys win
your scenario my heart is broken Chief
Super Bowl last leg of my uh Futures
part that's true you have a really nice
future plan yeah why did they give Bryce
yeah I think
I said I needed water it showed up
you're gonna be in the bathroom
uh my super big
Niners Chiefs win Brock Purdy has the
ball 13 seconds left overthrows a wide
open receiver down the field is that has
that ever happened before I was about to
say I don't even know
I don't think that's ever happened
before it would be pretty bad if it did
it would
game's about to start baby
boys
I found it very interesting that I think
we've all I might do I think rightfully
everyone's just out on the Eagles let's
go that's good yeah
Logan likes Seahawks having the ball
first for the first drive but yeah I
said score dang I I regret that now it's
it's a tough bet it is a tough bet
let's go Bobby
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's a good kick
oh yeah hey hey you know who made that
attack
Jordan Mason
please
here we go Gino Smith through over 4 000
yards 30 touchdowns this year wow yeah
11 picks had a great year oh
it's all over yeah
my only analysis
she probably went to DK what's that the
ball probably should have went to DK on
that place
will you drop the screenshot of the
parlay and the oh yeah it's my social
chemistry don't worry Sam we're all
right Brock hasn't seen the Phil yet
just an absolute disaster start
it's over we're covering
now here comes a little play action
no not on second and one yeah 100 100
let's go
never mind
[Applause]
let's go I'm in one of those positions
where I like bet just about everything
so it's like it's like when you're in
like five bandages
South Carolina right yeah is that
frowned upon
I know
about Niner that's like that's hard for
me because
what third and two not the curse no
nothing oh that's a curse you can curse
on these while having real money on them
throw the ball Gino pick six yeah let's
throw it
fix it hey go get a Bosa come on delay
of games
[Applause]
so it's just these guys I can't
celebrate Ryan
I got too much going on right now
Armstead no was that Bosa no
I know
yeah feed that man oh God all right
it's gonna be a short Pottery
right right back here Ray Ray's back
here
we're gonna need that Niners touchdown
I don't think they called it but we
lined up offsides
first that's right right oh we got a lot
of our first CDs are up right now
[Applause]
we're back okay Bryce said your ass is
in the jackpot get in that first stop no
questions
in a curse word that's true it's not one
of those seven words you can't say it's
not what's the chat let's engage
yourself let's Engage The Man in the
chat uh T Gambino was very upset that he
didn't get a chance to put his ticket in
uh Dylan Nguyen doesn't like my Cowboys
prediction because he thinks Tom Brady
is going to cook them yeah okay yep he's
wrong is the chat riding with us on
niners uh
then by us I mean like half of us
[Laughter]
the people that matters yeah
oh my God oh my God he's got time oh my
god
dude what was that what the heck is this
game
bro I mean we had them in the shoes
bro that was tough to see it Brock 13.
you know that was Iowa State rock party
right there
now you have to run on this play which
is so predictable and it's gonna be one
yard and it's third nine now we're
punting and now the game's over we lost
[Applause]
what do we take for McCaffrey anytime
touchdown
oh this is the Devo
e
somebody Ready Cash let's go one bet one
yeah last time I was here I got no
business
[Applause]
got a little green Mark in there all
right uh I needed him to house that
though so well we need brought Purdy the
house now
[Applause]
McCaffrey y'all McCaffrey here gotta
watch paycock
let's play clock come on time okay thank
God I did that first time out thank God
who said Niners first time out not me I
almost succeeded
I want to know though one check mark
baby oh man me and you both baby
yeah let's go Logan let's go that first
throw
no it was a bad throw outside
yeah he is kind of floating it yeah you
know I rock with the three by two could
have been a water bottle ah Elon rock
with the three bites well that was how
many minutes a game Bryson are you sure
that 100 sure this is mine yeah because
mine is right here and it's gone okay
Fair all right here we go
Stoney bones said he used his no sweat
bet
uh yeah that's awesome I love that we'll
send you socks we have socks yeah you
guys want socks to the chat we got socks
just drop sock emojis
[Applause]
I put money on that too on what'd you do
on first first touchdown I think any
time no you're supposed to do first yeah
she's not turned I took his total over
there what are we looking at and I don't
want to settle for field goals in this
weather like yeah he was wide open
oh
he is the best player in the league he's
amazing
so good McCaffrey hasn't touched the
ball yet has he I don't think so this is
a good idea
territory in this weather yeah why not a
territory here we might not get there
Sam but I hear you I'm just saying you
got two plays to work with I do hear you
yeah
I don't know if you know but zero zero
is an even number I think technically
oh they're letting the young men throw
they're letting the young man throw no
Debo it's a hand drawing
that's why you run that there to set up
the ability to go for on fourth no
you're right yeah
I forgot that I have the 49ers team
total on these passes yeah
that's a really bad decision
two red zones for Juwan Jennings I'm
very nervous about this yeah I'm really
nervous
yeah
in the elements 34 yards come on I don't
like this this is automatically
automatic
instead of the Raiders I'm so surprised
that that's 100 he was gonna make that
he's as good as gold all right we're
good 3-0 we should be upstairs
Niners my two and a half stop the count
I think that's a win that's a win and a
half
yeah
still upset about the uh was it Juwan
Jennings is that who that was said he
should have threw it earlier
yeah he's a rookie though personally I
would have threw it all right
I'm all in on I have no monies left the
elements
yeah he's a rookie in the elements
are you going to bed after this or it'll
be cash how's the chat doing
Chad come talk with us we'll give you
socks yeah drop those socks vibe I'm
feeling good guys I need Geno Smith to
throw the rock a little bit yeah I'm
gonna hold the football give him some
good vibes I'd like to know if we have a
um
a playback of the Highlight Reel of me
with the papa shot before the show
started wow I think get hot no no I
didn't get hot I started hot and I
stayed hot and I don't think I missed
more than three of them conveniently we
probably don't with all the oh I think
we did there's no recorder
and the papa shot
there's no air first of all first of all
there are people who put hard work into
inflation yeah yeah that's that's the
first of all second of all what does it
matter the the it feels rigged
yeah yeah just saying okay Matt throwing
that up yeah I think it was 88 Logan
should we just send an alert like yeah
all right guys just to get people in
yeah
you cut a 19-yard pass and Christian
McCaffrey didn't touch the ball one time
uh so yeah I'm tired but you know like
that's not gonna continue that's true I
just don't like the way that Purdy's
throwing the ball right now so it's like
it doesn't look great it doesn't look
like no we might ask the elephants
Ritter's under might be live but this we
might have to win this by defense which
yeah also shout out anyone who took uh
49ers team total under 26 and a half
that might have been the best bet of the
year I mean I don't know who did that
it's pretty early yeah but you know if
you saw this right side though yeah he's
not throwing the ball well but we only
need what 10 yards from my uke yes and
we need four catches from McCaffrey
which is perfect for him what do we what
else those are dump dates the locket the
locket thing I don't know did anyone who
shouted that out and said pocket the
chat was all over the chat was all over
like yeah that was a chat play that
should have been hey we can get that in
one place we can and that's what we said
that I feel better we talked about his
exceptions
which is probably smart come on we know
Shanahan's gonna dial up at least two
screens to McCaffrey yeah I like these
kickoffs man right like right at the
number right
oh no go oh no okay
[Applause]
why do we love that I what why do we
love that
we have the Seahawks yeah but Greg and I
need the Niners and I need nothing to
happen the rest of them so we don't need
that just special that was good for
Vince and I here's what we need don't
say we need
that was a good outcome for football
only we can say week no I'm just kidding
Gino throw the ball
gonna throw the ball yeah buddy hey
take it yeah get in there green law get
in there
uh
uh koi boy is asking who's stopping Bosa
and Mac no one
am I who's the mack he's referring to
Mattress Mack probably for killing That
Snack
Joey Bosa and clip and uh
I have no idea Joey Bosa oh Chargers
that's on our screen now we're talking
Seahawks Niners here throw the ball Gino
throw it pick oh no
it again what was it again reception 29
again
it's my best bet it's your bracelet no
words you know about the best what was
your best I know over four and a half
receptions for DK question
easy yeah just hit me
right and to be honest that [ __ ] first
rookie dude they should be trying to see
Robins absolutely Louise sharp on the
scene can he catch it I don't know but
they should be trying to feed no no no
he can catch it he should have at least
like 11 targets here's what I wouldn't
do here I wouldn't run the ball I think
that's a ball start please hey this is
this is Bosa Time come on come on play
action
oh yeah
[Applause]
are we here Gibson yeah
get over there this defense is just oh
yeah why are we so awesome I'm
not too concerned yeah Logan's not
concerned I'm a little nervous I kind of
want to bet Seahawks money line honestly
live Seahawks live what's up waste your
money I'll I'll take it he'll take your
bed with odds what are the Seahawks it's
uh it's 11 and a half right now is the
spread I'll take your bet I'll pay out
whatever it is
buying the points that's what you want
classic Ryan backfire uh
yeah right now Seahawks are plus 470 on
the money line if anyone's interested
anybody anybody anybody comes right up
here Logan I'll take that I'll House the
bet for you
hey man I'll give you
a live odds boost all right
[Laughter]
but we have a live band what uh yeah
this may have been literally 45 seconds
ago
I don't feel good about this live bet
the Seahawks money lines so now you're
welcome
he got money to blow I guess
that's wild bro
uh jackets jumped in here uh I'm cooking
a fan of the show you tell me about his
ass like hitle anytime how do you feel
about that Greg not in general I like it
throwing the ball in the first drive I
like it
once we transition
it's a lot of variables Ryan it's
elements rookie quarterback that's true
we saw how he was throwing the ball in
the first drive right which was you know
no offense not good yeah so I don't know
I agree I think before the game like the
idea of like kiddle just continuing to
stay hot was good he was like plus 145 I
think on DraftKings uh I don't know
we've seen like five minutes of this
game so far and I just I mean what's no
offensive score this drive what's the
odds uh no offensive score is minus 170.
no for no no that's a score we could do
this they're gonna tour
the Niners are going to score
uh tell us what you're sweating I don't
know that's a one that's wild odds to be
on the 10-yard line bro it's like for a
guy that threw the ball the other team
twice last Drive I believe honestly I
agree and so you say no no yeah I say
yeah there's one live bet from Vince
that's it so far welcome it's early
minus one second
but when I was getting in the lab
placing bets for everybody Ryan alone I
said he's in he's cooking I'm in support
all right guys yeah we got one live bet
wins and then Bryson was talking about
no offensive uh score on this drive we
got a heavy dose of Debo in the first
drive
this drive
Kettle you think it's Kettle okay all
right so you're with jackham in the chat
who's all over Kittle anytime touchdown
well I don't know if I'm over that but I
think Kelly's gonna get some yards all
right our boy kettle's gonna eat
Vince all right here we go plus 750 now
on the money line there's because you
can't do it because that's gonna be a
spoiler what just happened
you can't you can't that's that's rule
number one when you have the odds board
up you can't you can't out loud yeah
yeah right like you gotta go in timeout
so stand over there hey you gotta make
three in a row come on
I'll make the first time
[Laughter]
in a row
[Applause]
an l two
three
oh no oh yeah
[Applause]
we missed the first place
oh yeah what happened that was uh I
don't know check the live odds and tell
us before
Elijah who was that guy that said no
offensive score this year we could I
feel like the music
you know him saying oh they're spot
something now
uh is there anything worse than the
person I mentioned the game that has
odds is that him was that minus three
that's not good for my problem when we
get poached by Eli Mitchell oh God spoil
are people spot to spoil the game no I
don't know what I'm just saying yeah
oh this is
[Applause]
that the conference they about to give
it to Eli I'm sorry no oh like bootleg I
feel you I like that I like that I'm
telling
that was like his fourth option Bryson
all right here we go oh here we go oh no
where is McCaffrey here we go stop him
stop him I told y'all they were giving
up oh McCaffrey time get Jordan Mason in
there you failed you failed get
McCaffrey in get McCaffrey in yeah we
need McCaffrey back again who had uh
49ers uh for the first TD
um like 49er players I had CMC I got
party
I got Kenneth Walker
McCaffrey
McCaffrey Caffrey and Devo it's it's
this is like bootleg bootleg is our time
don't run it
[Applause]
let's go let's go oh my God guys
[Applause]
bro let's go
every time
[Applause]
Seahawks plus 11 and a half still
covering my heart is pumping so fast
great start Seahawks plus 17. let's
[ __ ] let's go I'm so sorry let's go
the road to Arizona Starts Now starts
today
I need to go take my how many countries
did he get on that drive was that one
that first one
oh well bad beat for Diva Logan all good
or need me for anything uh no I said
that I was gonna send plus 470 but
they're now 17 and a half Point dogs
or we could I use the anytime
which Greg we didn't discuss that you
you have 49ers money line yes and and
you have Bosa over a quarter sack minus
460 yeah she was like minus 700.
yes I get that you don't care about the
odds it's sprinkled in what do you mean
what do you mean hey man but that
doesn't values value brother yeah I'm
looking for wins
the Niners are going to win any amount
of money on their money line is good
value thank you Bryson
all he has to do is get a half a second
I win Geno Smith's down 10-0 he's going
to be throwing the ball in the elements
can I get a take from the chat on this
about how we feel about betting forces
and and minus 275 defensive place can we
yeah
460 money line is sprinkled into a
parlay okay they asked me for a bet I
gave them the one Niners money line but
the Nick Bosa thing is they make most of
things that's a play value minus 275.
all he has to do is get a half minus
275. we just hit the anytime TD boost
look can we even yeah
and celebrate it
well the very last play of this game you
won a bet yeah that was pretty cool
that was cool uh we need Gina to start
throwing them yeah he's down 10 points
while we're on the subject of things in
the chat I'm setting live line Bryson
Stricker sports book
nine and a half times that Greg uses in
the elements
yeah and Logan had McCaffrey all right
I thought uh Ryan or Logan did you hear
me yeah
bad beat
so it's just a straight-up reaction
that's good come on me I'm trying to get
a cash
yeah yeah I have seen no semblance of
life for the Seahawks to score points so
yeah
reply to our guys
that's what we said right I'm gonna tell
me to clip that actually I'm not he's
not gonna post it I'm not gonna post
something Betty I'm gonna post it on my
personal
melly's on the case shout out Melly
working hard shout out Millie go get him
Bosa
oh he that was a freaking Foster
yep Oh I thought that would be play
action I don't like this we got to stop
I saw bribery strick drop in the chat uh
Kenneth Walker rushing attempts over I
think that's what we should have taken
to be honest I will say this we're we're
at this game game script is setting up
towards Niners get like one more
touchdown the Seahawks are gonna have to
abandon the run and start though yes so
the first thing is they're gonna go
three and out so we're gonna get three
passes yeah you're right yeah are we
still at one passing we got a live bet
in the chat Debo next TD score from oh
that's fun too that's fun
hey watch Bosa get that sack also we got
some more people floating up here
what up what up challenge
okay I mean definitely a bad pass
members yeah welcome tell us what you're
betting give the channel
let us know if that was the most gross
display of DPI you've ever seen
man
[Applause]
is
thank you
reception no you should make your
receptions hey we got our boys
just a cramp that's a cramp it's all
right we got we got death that
linebacker I'm not sure uh the onions is
giving you some love Greg you said Greg
would be fun to watch a game with I
agree yeah
then it's okay
we exorty and said what's up boys just
cash CMC anytime
[Applause]
you know what really sucks is the the
suckers and losers uh before this game
who were clowning Us online for the CMC
anytime boost and now they're now
they're both sad and poor and poor and
poor over a thousands
they're not yeah if I had the power to
stop Christian McCaffrey from scoring a
touchdown I wouldn't be betting a
thousand dollars on the game brother let
me just tell you that
I've got
I've got oh my God
Jesus man all right let's go come on
let's go let's go clearly things are
going well again first eight minutes of
this game Oh Mr Diet Coke jumping in
here it said sleeper Play No touchdown
scored for the Seahawks
no it's not a super play anymore the
value it's like yeah
I agree yeah let's see let's see I agree
it also aren't they a little like
located
uh nice uh no Seahawks TD Ryan are you
ordering food oh exordian only about my
CMC bed because of you what do we want
so shout out oh that's cool hundo richer
we'll send you something we love that
you got socks I think it's I also think
it's great let's have the one guy here
who doesn't have a company car to order
the food I think that's fair yeah I
think yeah for sure definitely uh I
can't say anything but um
I what are you what do we guys what do
we want what are we feeling
always lands huh dudes watching sports
eating pizza oh okay yeah I can do some
Zach
what I gotta do for us uh tell us what
we should order in the chat yeah sure
what should we get for lunch in the chat
dude it's five o'clock dinner oh uh
centrico Burson uh said Saturn poor
three laughing emojis thanks for the
free 50.
you're welcome let's ask the chat uh
what's best to eat when you're down
tremendously bad and well Taco Bell wow
that's that's great Taco Bell is the
best why are you down bad though
we're also not covering I send you down
that road
I would like a defensive player in a
year
[Applause]
no I do like the physicality Moody baby
says a Crunchwrap Supreme solves all oh
absolutely that's send him some space
there it is uh Michael bowling wants to
know how many bathroom trips for Bryson
currently we're at zero over under is
I'm the only one that says he took two
last time yeah I'm setting the line
should be set at two to give the sports
book like some safety at two okay and
that way people really gotta put just
put it to the test another run
stop running the ball he's drunk half a
cup of water so it's the elements
that's our second d-line in there wait
till they put the starters oh I love
that Empanada Mama wreck for bowling
right guys
that is his like three blocks away too
it could be really I could do that
that's a leading Contender who's going
to go pick up the delivery food I
thought we got someone's got to lose a
bet to have to go do that right like
could be I mean I want to know me and
Greg are both want to know right now so
not us
oh I like lock it watch Lockheed yeah I
was just about to say on this jacket
okay
[Applause]
any points because that's our second
string d-line out there LeBron and
Russia in the locker room let's get
greedy uh Bryson Jacob in the chat says
yes you're over at two he's taking he's
taking you over I can respect that yeah
it's one of those like yeah break the
seal once it rains it pours type
situation yeah yeah
I I see that halftime will have a good
temperature and also too I drink water
slower out of cups and last time I had
bottles okay
oh the football I know this is kind of
insane how they thought it what twice
four times yeah uh exordian just said he
put his winnings from CMC on Tyler
Lockett to be the second touchdown score
so he needs Tyler Lockett here
interesting I mean Tyler login from
right here with Dash I bet right or
close to close to yeah
okay yeah
go get them Bosa
lockets wide open I saw him
yep throw it again baby we're chipping
away
Bryson Susie Susie releases off the line
lockets
Dylan Wynn 2 says if Devo scores next
49ers Drive I need 10 push-ups out of
Greg or Ritter
[Applause]
two large pies
uh if anyone has a recommendation on
Pizza in New York please drop that yeah
whatever's right here preferably a place
that is a little wings as well I need a
little chicken wing oh I got a little
Joe's Pizza in my ear all right never
heard of it yeah
I'm down sounds good Joe's Barbecue yeah
I've never been from case yeah somebody
driving some Joe's Barbecue because that
would slap right now it's pretty cool
that we hit that uh that was pretty
boost yeah that was fun
that's the thing the only thing we're
not on Pace for is the Gino over correct
well they even lock it we're overpays
for as long as the Niners keep scoring
Gino's gonna have to throw this yeah
um
I'm hungry
okay he's getting angry folks
we should we should just get a hundred
percent that would be so good Applebee's
is across the street just plain you just
want plain pizza what does that mean
cheese clarify what you mean by plain
pizza
is that a New York thing plain pizza
is that not a thing is that yeah wait is
that what happens
like cheese pizza are you saying the
cheese pizza yeah just that's a point is
this real no this is a bear anyone with
a cheese pizza
oh my goodness are we actually being
here
no one has ever said oh my goodness what
planet do you live on that nobody has
ever seen has ever said
I've never heard that no one has ever
seen we got you right man
here's the thing
[Laughter]
meaning there's nothing on it but what
is regularly on a pizza
tomato sauce and cheese no everyone just
has a cheese pizza I'm getting a cheese
pizza and a pepperoni it's called a
cheese I feel like a cheese pizza is
like a redundant statement it's like an
oxymoron yeah
should we get a plain pizza like
somebody said cheese pizza
all right
yeah
this is like this is jarring to me right
now I I actually can't believe this oh
they got wild cat oh we bought the stuff
what is going on yeah is this a joke
[Applause]
beside the store with the ball right now
that's like actually I don't know that's
working though they're marching why
would they not do really well it's
working earning every yard baby oh my
God it is working it's gonna ruin your
life well yeah okay well I'm being
yelled at in my ear that it's because
New Yorkers uh build their Pizza in line
and there's an option for toppings and
no toppings I never I don't build my
pizzas
dial up my phone I call and I say hey
dudes can I get a lot of dominoes who's
building the pizza yeah I don't know
Blaze Pizza maybe like shout out
to the chat saying we gonna be betting
usfl this summer we're gonna be betting
XFL is what we're gonna do oh that'll be
that's true all right
for everyone is that fine is that is
that cool yeah it does the trick is
there a chicken meat that'll do it
oh man are we getting hurt who who it's
one of our alignments oh no Ryan where
are we at on the chicken wings
what's this place called that you're
looking at it's uh uh Joe and Pat's
Pizza Hey Joe yes yeah uh it's the
original ones the Staten Island so I
haven't had the New York one but it's
very large Vince brought stuff in the
1960s no it's great it's great it's good
if you like a thin super thin yeah yeah
okay I'm a big thin crust guy I like a
yeah crunch so depend on that
you're not a thing you're not a thing no
I'm a huge thing oh okay I don't like a
doughy crust gotcha they have wings
Bryson thank god oh do you want a water
what if I want some salad too you're on
the menu it's just scoping out the menu
for you because Bryson was very
concerned about the wing situation I
have salad what if I want wings that's
not as anyone close to cashing anything
yeah I'm 45 minutes away okay cool uh a
plain pizza uh pepperoni pizza get me
out of here dude take me back to Kansas
you're on this train too it's a cheese
pizza yeah wait what did the chat say
uh Stoney bones who lied and told you
that we don't build our pizzas thank you
good good well good job
Logan pulling the first TV Square out of
the Hat again two things yeah wait you
know yeah
that's what I was absurd yo that's
that's pretty impressive what are the
odds too especially from the [ __ ]
lavishka I think was like 15. the look
on your face
I think what we should do to pick who
has to go down and grab the food when he
gets here is whatever the over under or
whatever the time it says that it's
going to arrive we choose a number
everyone has to choose a number based
off that number okay furthest away okay
or we don't even get the hit number we
just we're gonna blindly guess okay I
like the blind guys I like that the
blind guy's gonna be so brutal when it
says two hours and we're all out here
guessing like 35 minutes Ryan just let
us know when you put the order in so we
can yeah sure lock in our bets I'll let
you guys know
okay
[Music]
yeah it's about to say it has taken
forever well there was an injury I don't
know how many buffalos
yeah
all right
it's not a ranch
[Music]
it's the top top thing be discreet when
you pull it out so some scammer doesn't
you know
do we want to request utensils sure all
right yeah yeah cool
please throw the ball they're not going
to
oh
first down
all right I have his passing yards I'm
not
we're dead
right down our throats
garlic bread
yeah this is yeah why would you even
have to ask a little little sprinkle
yeah okay yeah yeah garlic bread minus
500.
this is such [ __ ] dude
it's not fair
oh we're good
it's like an eight minute drive it feels
like play action oh they're ruining my
life anytime baby yes
[Applause]
we're back no no no no he was looking
back like we're back 2-0 to an hour your
predictions looking good live money yeah
we're still alive on mine I mean just
wait here comes the missed Pat to just
get us all off I'm gonna freak did you
go at 3-0 down
uh yes big time
Charles cross
[ __ ] so we're uh we're back we're
plus 410 right now I won't say right
here
31-10.9 and a half so we're right back
we're right back in it we're right back
to the beginning we can't gotta make it
right here missed
oh my God need those points
how about that uh odd score right should
we uh should we get a live bet in on
this day shout out to uh
we're feeling it
I do like that uh whoever was tossing
out the the Debo next touchdown yeah
what's the chat saying odds would have
been nice
yeah Seattle score vods are low yeah
Bob's over here you guys are lying like
she's all the way across the country
this is firing off beds this isn't right
a lot no I love live betting I mean
little sprinkles live TV scores
next TD scored somebody said Debo Plus
700. is that what it is yeah that's
pretty good
Brock Prairie you got to come out and
look good Sam I might I'm gonna say you
know what I'm gonna do a press this is
probably the most important drugs
that was just way too easy kind of scary
and we knew they were running it every
single day that was a long drive in the
Box the whole time I'm going Debo next
touchdown score live hey seven to one
that's fun I love that wait has UFC
started I forgot I have all these UFC
bets I got to worry about
parlayed with odd
oh it has oh my God I'm like why let's
go let's go whoa
what's up baby let's go
that's gonna be big I want some dude
round one no I I my guy that I had money
on one in the first round by sub I
didn't have it I think it's Dylan win
too
I'll just type it in I don't know maybe
I should have just bought this pizza and
not in hindsight Dylan win too
what's he saying he's he's the one that
was recommending shout out Dylan win too
socks yep we'll get some socks for you I
jumped on Debo and also off the Record
show under betters on Greg Ivory saying
uh in the elements are like looking
looking good right now looking pretty
good it's been a minute well we haven't
got the ball yet
rookie quarterback's gonna come out
oh
yeah we can pull that up on that really
good moment too did you bet it I don't
know
this is uh this is where you're gonna
dig down deep Whopper wow
we should have just got a bunch of
Whoppers we should have yeah that's yeah
I wouldn't I wouldn't call that
hindsight I don't
20 20. huh that could be the move for
the uh Jaguars game
right
this is horseshit dude should we have 35
nothing sorry we're about to go up 17-7
he's limping
oh no he's not seven minutes 14 plays
I want to get some player to catch a
pass on this drive going
that's a fun bat catching the pass on
this drive what do those lines looking
like
200. watch the slant got locked we this
this needs to be like a long it's that
Delight damn it down their throat type
of drive we really established
methodical that we're a five-star men
who's watching my ESPN plus right now it
says I'm at my streaming limit
you know what it is I bet ku's playing
on ESPN plus man probably this is the
worst thing that's ever happened to me
they are playing Iowa State Iowa State
oh man
that's kiddle oh that's not you
[Applause]
guys
[Applause]
go baby I don't know
but on the graphic where it says the
parlay can we put a check to the legs
that have already might be that might be
good is that possible
or something
yeah oh I like the green text reception
I love that how about that
nice I don't like that keep the ball in
Purdy's hands right now
it's just an idea keep the ball in g13's
hands right now I mean it's no no one is
gonna be I'm talking to the producer
talking to producer Max uh
it's up there we did it yeah there's
check there it is I see it oh nice
okay that wasn't that hard to give me a
bunch of [ __ ] for that
okay okay fair fair
y right here
perfect little check down 11. perfect
perfect
[Applause]
did you lock that in every bed
and also too that was a lot though we
should put it in the parlays that's
definitely what happened yeah
didn't we dip out
in the first quarter like it was we saw
the stats we were he had him passion
once in the last like seven weeks in our
defense
better step in the elements did you do
the little the little baker a little
heavy
is who Joe is like what mainstream
America wants Joe burrow Rock Purdy is
Joe cool that was Joker
[Applause]
the receiver case
was looking big
bro to be honest uh you I know iuk was
down there but they were showing evil
like the route was supposed to fall he
must have failed he was Wi-Fi
[Applause]
that's that's foreign
I do like that
yeah run also you're not a lot of
loading forward for the snap by it was
like basically CFL sprinting up the
field before he snapped the wall
I don't like this call a [ __ ] timeout
Shanahan they didn't call it
kiddo get up field boy yeah easy that
was me that was risky
yeah that's risky paid off
Yak second best time in the football
let's go baby yeah well with Brock Purdy
he might be the first someone else
and Kelsey I'm just saying I'm I'm just
saying he's a rookie better not be what
happened they just I think they blew a
whistle so I'm just assuming someone's
hurt
I hope no one's hurt
somebody might be hurt because they're
taking heck of long to get back to the
play
maybe not
Seattle
Rock
I mean I'm just reading what it said
it is what the sign said their words not
ours
how we feeling guys everybody's looking
out the trash and down in their phone
check it out I would love a Niners touch
down here because that's going to make
this right how's the ETA for the food I
like the way you think
we're supposed to guess who you yelling
at him all right let's just do over
under uh we have somebody bringing it to
us no punishment yeah well [ __ ] man we
getting first class service can I get
some more water shout out
to CMC the story it's doing that thing
for me where it doesn't do it yeah just
throw like a fire slider under it or
something tag DraftKings
of Paul Giamatti what do you think of uh
liar or uh yeah yeah yeah always bfl is
just awesome all-time movie therefore
the blue scene is like yeah that's
Avatar too way of water yeah that's what
the movies
it is strutting out to it do you know
who sings that song
now for for the ten dollars can you name
those things that song who sings which
song Hungry Hungry Like the Wolf little
baby close Okay do I get like a time
limit right now
I'll give you a 30 seconds starting
right now he's looking it up
can you give us
he's in the chat so is the chat is
telling you Durant oh Duran Duran did
they say it in the chat no they didn't
oh hold on Duran Duran time to be real
max set it in your ear let's be real
time
you offer hold on you offer no that you
cheated
I agree
so we we're just we're not men of our
our word here you are going at your word
by cheating
I
says who you're not a five-star I don't
know I don't know about that you're
losing your five stars I literally
posted something that you said the other
day and you said that you said in the
chat all right
I said I said no such thing
where's my guy Dylan Wynn too Dylan win
two we're gonna get it right here Debo
in the back field
he's wired in it's wired in he's
changing the play
toss okay
that's another what a boy that looked
terrible but it was perfect
but your dong leg of Gino is gonna ruin
Christmas for everyone in this dude in
what world is Geno not getting 30 passes
I think we're at like seven right
they're losing by 70. everyone stay calm
yeah they're gonna run the ball until
the end of the half well he's like hey
shout out to Adam lefko who said my
khakis are tight hey
thank you does he have any plates yeah
let's go what do you want in this game
yeah lefco comes in here and comments on
your kids
those khakis are tight with a laughing
face
[Applause]
is there all birds
I've been down in these they're flexible
oh they looked at him
[Applause]
I'm not gonna like I was gonna go to the
bathroom
all right all right so you're sitting on
we have one before halftime is that no
that's that cow yeah
said yeah bro I meant if you farted your
shoes might pop off
wow great response
okay that's tough you know what coming
up
it's a very on brand very on brand for
Philadelphia
[Applause]
I learned my lesson I don't want to
bring this with me
I really don't like that play just turn
it off yeah let's uh no I just turned
out there should be a switch is there
not Robbie goes about the cast before my
last bathroom trip I over I
overestimated what's that audio what's
that backdrop
all right field goal time
not good are you still recovering from
that burn oh no that was gonna be honest
with you I'm probably never gonna get
over that one because I didn't need to
call that out I could have just let that
live in the chat yeah I would know it or
what I ever know shout out Melly
they're flexible
rushing yards they look tight because
you have them all the way up here like
yeah I mean I don't know where you go
that's like let them hang bro I can
squat
you got to let them hang though bro uh I
don't know I kind of I don't know what
what else is he saying he's on I don't
let's go be honest with you man I don't
care what you're on anymore I don't but
since you dropped it in here uh I'm on
CNC rushing yards over CMC touchdown and
congrats you cash what do you do it
might be pretty close to hitting after
that big run and kill touchdown
I haven't seen that many Eli Mitchell
appearances which is good no not not
good not great food it doesn't get tired
second half guys and he's a little
banged up yeah because the material he
lost three yards on a carry it's like
golf these are like golf no that's
pretty good like this is thicker
material but it also like we're not
doing great
squat offs shall we squat yeah uh what
was the rushing yards over for 64.
um
you know what the uh
done sex with two and a half to go
oh did you check you're standing in the
way by the way but uh not great do you
uh do you know what the rushing yards
over under was for McCaffrey Bryson is
crazy he took 65 plus yeah yeah
I think it was you that passed on it
yeah how many receptions we took it out
because we went reception I'm sorry I
think when everyone leaves the nerves
what is he on yeah
the wrong even number okay and we're on
an even number now it won't stay like
and my BET's not looking oh lefco says
Greg is Right Eli Mitchell is a great
live BET right now so it's a score I
mean you got my Debo bridge that to know
that I was right I'm just saying you got
support
he's in the jackpot right okay yeah Max
can you tell Sam if my mic's back on
thank you what
I don't know I don't have I can't they
can't talk it's on oh you said it you
you've you've switched up the names but
yes it's on uh 74 and a half of CMC
thank you Dylan win too appreciate it
look at the passer ratings by my guy
Brock
he's better than my homes that's
incredible
he's incredible
games
he needs to play like the defensive
player of the year yeah I got an idea
Niners five yards that are not nice
Seahawks five yards at a time outro pick
six in the end zone I like it
so we get like seven passes in a pick
six we all win except Ryan with his plus
a lot I don't love that to be honest I
don't know that I don't know
that felt against the rules man
yeah that could have been really bad
uh it sounds like the McCaffrey rushing
over it's at 72 right now he's at 72
right now and it was 74.5 he's already
at 72 yeah which is kind of nice four
rushes on four rushes yeah that one that
one yeah
I had an idea when I was going to walk
all right here we go we got we need to
get a
sponsored
to sponsor our show with DraftKings that
we can use out there and I can have it
in the supply list DK all right it's
gonna be a pass DK let's go whatever
whatever oh I like that I like that 87.
I like that hit Drake three and out
Niners touchdown and get two minute
drill Geno to drive down the field yeah
we get well six passes seven passes how
are we at seven passes man all right uh
shout out to Raheem who wants us to
start building 93 yards
but yeah MLG uh I have no right Raheem
42 right in the chat
nine leg same game parlay dude we can't
even hit five we're gonna run around
here right now
all right we can't hit five because
no bad vibes let's go hey hey hey
Seahawks Seahawks dude this is Seahawks
Seahawks birds fly together Seahawks Yep
this is our third time playing them you
know all right yeah
they make a lot of adjustments
okay we're going to need we need 40
right
45. I'm here got 13 yards on two catches
that's wild come on that was awesome
[Applause]
yeah they're sliding on that Turf okay
that was me rat pants now is the new
nickname oh man
said I just know Greg's chair is
uncomfortable can you confirm hey I'll
take the hawk man yeah it is kind of
kind of uncomfortable
right here one play One Stop get up
right here
this is it come on
a year coming back go get him don't say
oh watch 29 watch 29 up top pick six
come on pick six would be so beautiful
here no delay of game
get there oh DK
[Applause]
let's go monster dog touchdowns
so bad it's over
fly together baby
wow yo Greg don't forget
[Applause]
how about them Seahawks wow
you catch TK receptions
yeah yeah oh did I cash it no I think
that's Arena
oh man we're gonna need 21 pass attempts
from Geno Smith in the second half God
and the closer the closer this game is
come on yeah that's cute but I don't
know if they're gonna keep leaving them
open like that that was huge
to one
not gonna be 31-10 today if we can get a
uh a nice little close-up of Sam's face
right now I think the audience would
like to see that I mean it's over yeah I
just want to say something bro
imagine if you'd take a first Half-Life
money line but that [ __ ] was looking
good we should have looked at that yeah
we're not gonna live in that world Bryce
yeah that's one of my favorite things to
do in college basketball is when like a
heavy favorite goes down early yeah
their live line is not normally that
good but the first half live money line
will be like plus 500 and it's like dude
how do we lose the [ __ ] Seahawk
I mean that was a dime all right yeah
that was a dime that was beautiful yeah
that was that was the difference between
especially when they've established the
run this has been their offense All
Season yeah
look at you I didn't think they would
you know and to like to their credit
they didn't abandon the run after like
those first two disastrous exactly Pete
Carroll the last this is this is right
playing right into his hand we did talk
about this though every single person
bet either a money line parlay of Niners
bills or they teased it and we said
there's no chance that that the smash is
that yeah and this is it's gonna be
right off the bat everyone's gonna lose
it right off that's how you the books
the books will cook everyone off the
bats everybody's gonna chase into the
Cowboys
Robbie Gold for the winter
that's unbelievable
not great
touch down here
same as pregame
oh wow now Niners minus six is that the
right time for me to remind people that
I have this
a Niners future but
it's fine all right come on diva
we need to score a touchdown with 10
seconds that ball game now Sam our
defense isn't playing this seems to be
the last possession of the half and it
needs to have points oh Brock knows how
to he knows how to run a four meter yeah
like yeah he's definitely really good
playing the clock here our defense isn't
playing like the number one defense they
haven't been for the last couple weeks
man
the first two drives is like all right
they're doing it and then they like got
now they got the [ __ ] kicked out of 116.
and we got to score touchdowns not field
goals I agree
I don't like that I don't like that yuck
this could be really cool
I mean if we have to punt and the
Seahawks hit the last position half that
would be really bad I am gonna go
unhinged on Kyle Shanahan here shortly I
usually I usually Reserve that until he
chokes away at NFC Championship game but
I am so sick and tired of hearing about
how good a coach Kyle Shan is and a guru
I mean he's a really really good coach I
don't care they're on their third string
quarterback and they're the best team in
the league get the job done I I hear you
I get the job done but he I also hear
Sam too he is a good coach but I hear
you this is the job this is the game
come on Brock see I feel confident when
the ball is in history let's go let's go
[Applause]
all right this is bad this is bad do we
start to Envision the reality where Tom
Brady that you stop it is this is a 49.
he's that's the second time
yeah behind him because he's going to be
a creature it'll be a free agent
afterwards we're going to save that
conversation
it may be human history and this is The
Vibes you want to bring right now I mean
listen fake it I'm just thinking ahead
all right Ryan it's an Ohio state says
to be honest take it you're the one
who's
yeah you got all this Penta cutting
energy that's on the deepest honestly
about your Cowboys
you've got on the Seahawks on the diners
no
ah what are we upset about no nothing I
just need I need to go under
oh yeah that's true yeah you do yeah I
don't need this to be a close game also
underrated right now Niners minus two
and a half in our parlay is getting
cooked
that would yo Ryan that would suck what
up dog Ryan yo what's going on man
everything is over I'm up I saw that you
have a Futures bet on the 49ers to win
the championship yes that's going to
make you more money than the bet that
you placed today it's gonna make me a
lot of money it's gonna make me a lot of
money yeah you're happy that the 49ers
aren't about to win we're gonna stop
them here we have not I wouldn't say I'm
happy that 49ers are losing you gotta
just commitment say that I'm happy that
the Seahawks are probably back Brock
party two minutes there's no way to see
that the Niners don't win this game I
mean right Sam zero percent zero zero
percent chance that the Niners don't win
I got the stream up
communities looking for some NBA locks
but NBA lines imagine looking for an NBA
lock on super Wild Card Saturday
um couldn't be us yeah could not be all
right 21 more passes come on honestly I
can live with this
they're gonna run the ball first play
give me a false start or something to
hold we need some Past Times come on the
highlighter one
we're good we're good we're good good
vibes
foreign
[Laughter]
hey hey play with this passion calm down
brother
take a deep breath all right we're okay
it's not over yo Greg what are your
inside sources on the Niners scene right
now man on the Niners what what are they
saying right now man I need some vibes
man
I don't know bro
this the way they're running the ball I
don't like it
oh yeah
and they let DK go deep like that that's
bad
that's not good vibes
the other Chad's doing
um it's over
jackham DK punishing Ward right now yes
yeah no kidding what is he doing yeah
he's getting destroyed
and I mean the attempts at tackling are
just yeah this is yeah
sad DK was due for sure
just what we need if I could cash this
DK receptions bet by half time I I mean
you're feeling good no I'd be feeling
great I'd be feeling great
they didn't even hear the Whopper
commercial
should we get this spreadsheet up to see
how we're tracking yeah let's do it
uh Ritter you this is more just like
correct scores it's done yeah Stevo next
TV I thought you're not completely done
with her because
you've lost no yeah
I'm Kenny Walker so I let's get a green
over there I'm not even having Reds up
there let's get a green let's get a
green bean next to Canada we just read
out Niners to win Super Bowl since
that's already lost
uh no because I have it under my name
That's a classic example right there
we're not uh I mean it's over
we're still fine Sam we're gonna we're
we are going to win it's over everything
is over
SF team total
uh
uh Hey first drive was a punt man Dylan
Nguyen is trying to though is incredible
just for the Niners defense looks so
good Greg this game is so early yeah
second half machine he has so much
confidence he's about to show it I'm not
worried neither am I our 49ers guys are
gonna win I'm not worried fives 49ers
fives it's over 49ers lives oh no no no
those aren't genuine Vibes yeah that's
yeah yeah I mean those aren't genuine
all right what are we talking about got
something I got hot fives over here yeah
yeah I mean don't make me do that
they're getting ready
because you're being that guy right now
there's like there's nothing worse than
that guy
what's the guys
and over into this realm
there's no negative Vibes let's go get
him that's big Sam that's big that is
Time Out call time out I want the ball
back call
Kyle Shanahan does that weird stuff bro
oh my God we're good though
we got Robbie Gold
should have been a four yards it's a
Robbie walk-off we're only gonna need 19
passes in the second half though that's
that's doable I guess this is it
everything in front of us right now go
get them one play one moment DK this
would be something that's not an
opportunity to like one second on the
clock and they might run it no
[Applause]
the past attempts may be cooked but the
49ers minus 2
oh stop it what are you Whispering back
there you're Whispering into a live no I
just don't I don't want to be excuse the
bad vibes the bad vibes yeah
yeah it is a little problems
about about the minus two and a half
he's going very much does it look great
I'm just saying it doesn't look like
Ryan's out here like
we don't have to pay him back again
oh no dude is the guy in the chat right
so you pushed that so hard you're
getting the job man okay all right I'll
show you with Bryson I I like the chat
Broadway guys we've got to keep the
Vibes it's like I don't want to be that
guy but when that was out there I was
definitely switch spots but I wasn't
gonna I wasn't gonna know uh
or before I first drive a second oh
McCaffrey McCaffrey though McCaffrey
McCaffrey though
uh
[Applause]
okay I don't know all right we're doing
some shades
[Music]
[Applause]
oh stop it
ha ha
yes they both play the quarterback
position only similarities well
both have over 100 passer ratings in
their first five career side let them
know let them know
that's where we're at need three went
from it's dead it's over season we're
comparing them to Mahomes I mean no I
agree with you yes
thank you yes yeah thank you
come on come on come on no DAC is not
nowhere near oh I ate too much of that
come on Brock lock in bro
you had the excuse the first uh the
first quarter oh my God yeah oh my God
beautiful
[Laughter]
I was
hey Ray you were making jokes like
seriously go compare Pat Mahomes numbers
and Brock party's numbers in their first
couple games
I got everything you got Sushi yeah he's
got a he's got a no one to bail on place
because you cannot just run straight
that was a big 12. it's over there
at least he threw it away you know what
I'm saying
that oh
oh
he got attacked what is that should be
15. flag
I want to be contrary
I don't like I like you so much
I don't think Integrity is something you
have a little of I think you either have
it or you know you know why we were
sometimes
Sidelines down on the ground for 27. a
man of integrity I like that Vince well
now we're playing that's unfortunate
all right they hadn't shown Brock's
parents all game I was kind of worried
maybe they weren't there so I feel like
we're back now get ready get ready
he's got him a factor oh my god oh
he's good he's good he's good he's
wasting time
but I just don't like he rose tonight
every time like they're gonna keep
rolling a Long Way
Maddie Mark used to roll the roll
honestly I would hand it off get six
yards yes this is he's gonna like take a
sack so clueless
he's good we ain't got no timeouts
checked out of McCaffrey please God no
uh well if we check down we gotta run on
the field quick and kick this field goal
because we have no timer fire drill
field goal coming 20 30 seconds is not
fire drill there's time
here he's gonna not get a delay a game
here
McCaffrey
he almost had that boy
man we need touchdowns we need
touchdowns we need touchdowns yeah but I
I don't know the condition is this wall
real at this point
I don't think it's real is there a wind
check can we Doppler that
that was a tidy bro that's not real that
was a toddy
it's a good throw yeah that's what the
chat saying about this year before we
get into halftime
hey Sam
hey he's as good honestly that's big
he's as good as gold
let's go baby
no Niners baby so hungry bang bang Niner
game excuse me brother gang bang bang
Niner gang
Seahawks covering Niners winning this is
exactly what I wanted Greg I explained
the situation to you I explained the
situation to you
thank you guys stressing me out guys
steam with some Papa shot that guy's
stressing me out I gotta shoot some
shots
bro we're in a tie game with Iowa State
right now what's going on in my life bro
Brock Purdy's ruining my life it was our
finals we lost by eight yeah something
like that
mizzou's Lin sanity run is over I I
don't like continuously setting hey why
breath sell iced I don't even know who
that is he's so iced on the sidelines
all right
it'll be really cool if Geno Smith threw
the ball here I was seeing what time it
was he's not going dude but it would be
cool
get a decent return to like the 45 that
way you have hope oh my God I don't like
that at all I love that I love that I
love that go down
now
we have three times
two more attacks the Hail Mary is what
I'm scared of no no we need locket why
are you getting back together we don't
care about your property we need lockage
pass attempts unlock it hey guys bang
bang Niner guys honestly an incomplete
pass and then like a Chuck he's like a
betting chameleon he's just navigating
his way in and out of everyone's that
slips yeah I don't like it I don't like
it
he is rapping he's a heavy rad stuff
right now this sucks a little snakey is
this this is you know here we go okay go
get him 97 this is where we get that
sack right here
TK oh DK you gotta follow us
oh
my God oh my God
Jimmy War why would you do that it's
still 50 plus yeah 55 oh yeah oh my God
that was literally the worst like if
you're gonna list off all the things
that are gonna happen on that play that
is the worst possible scenario
Seahawk Nation it's just we're alive and
well worst possible scenario why would
you do that bro
imagine if you grabbed Seahawks live
money line plus 10 000 two seconds ago
that's why you don't [ __ ] squid like
they did everything possible they squib
kick it and then it's like bro do you
know does anything besides run the ball
there it's been hey guys you know what
they're playing in oh this is gonna be
the elements he's making no way
bro he's kicking from the logo Sam
people don't do that in Santa Clara all
right I'm telling you this is there's
ocean breeze so this this would be the
first time there's storms
this doesn't happen in Santa Clara love
that has it ever happened before you
tell me Ryan well you're saying it's
never happened before you tell me we're
watching history you do go Google
something get on your computer and find
out
they don't know come on where's the
friend you need a fan yeah hold up we're
going to blow yeah we're gonna blow why
less
why left
it's over Dude
he's awesome to Seattle he's pulling
this 50s
who cares it's all about the blow well
it doesn't matter
I'm gonna get out of the way imma just
get out of the way right right
he made that it's good that's un whoa
[Music]
Seahawks live money line was like plus
five thousand at least their team total
was like 13. I'm just saying they're at
the end after the Niners score with nine
seconds 12 seconds left wow that's just
brutal I mean not just got the ball now
yeah they do all right we're good we're
good we're all right metal not one range
middle ranges not worried
not worried
all right Ryan what's the updated
what's up what's the updated ETA all
right y'all we want to chat thanks for
I'm on his side
any Futures things like that about us on
the alert you can cut the tension with a
knife
uh yeah you wanna you wanna create some
bets Logan great let's talk about this
weekend talk about our picks yeah
talk about how I think how things are
going that this weekend
that is such a bad Omen like I truly
believe they're not going to lose that
game like that is
that's unreal like why why did he do
that squib kick and [ __ ] like
there's eight seconds left when they
kicked off
it's over are we
would it be possible to to
rally The Vibes for a few minutes to
create some battles of course to give
give some weekend locks and give our
picks for for the Wild Card Weekend
first all right what are the parade some
uh M diesel says I have a Kittle tea TD
is much needed for my TD parlay
I don't know how to grade that
it's a current bet yeah George Kettle to
score a touchdown and the game that
we're watching he's taking that live he
already has it
I like it we got a couple Kittle titties
yeah does anyone have uh four letters
Plus on their phone or something
four letters plus you gotta come on oh
the summit please because I can't the KU
games like tied to like 17 seconds left
uh
uh okay let's create some more bets I
mean it just immediately got shut down
on Kittle titty I don't know what to say
uh there's I mean were you giving that
an F minus F minus live oh MD's I mean
if we do that we have to base that on
the quarterback play Brian are we
sending it into this corner yeah Logan
are we setting yeah
right
now is great I think that's a good I
think that's a good question that maybe
should be raised at this current moment
what is our what is our confidence meter
in Brock Purdy in the second half yeah
it's so over zero the game is over okay
um I will grade future bets someone
wants to talk Chargers Jags yeah all
right do you want to give your wheels
right now it's just like all right let's
give some some people a couple to get
into the chat alerts out even in
tonight's game we could break down the
Bucks Cowboys game I mean while we have
some time to kill
yeah I mean if you want if that's what
you want I mean I don't think we need to
do it yeah
yeah all right well let's talk Chargers
Jags first I'm on Chargers money line
that's the BR betting news
uh if you guys are signed up wow yeah I
just think like five two and two I love
it everyone is very in on the Jags right
now and they got outplayed by Josh Dobbs
and the Titans and they got negative one
yards in the fourth quarter Trevor
Lawrence looked awful and they got a
sack fun little credit to them but
that's a game that if you're a real
Contender which they are not you win
that game easily uh
would love the chat to let us know what
yeah your Jags Chargers in the meantime
or on this weekend in general in the
meantime does no Mike Williams scare you
it does that's that's the biggest
concern
um because I've you know I've said it a
lot but I think he is such an important
part of that offense like more so than
just a typical
star receiver on his team just because
he's really the only deep threat go ball
jump ball you know pick top on the
defense guy everyone else they have
doesn't really have that capability like
Keenan Allen's great he's going to run
get you seven yards on third down but it
really allows the Jags are going to be
able to really pack it in
um and that that's just a scary thing so
would have felt a lot better if he was
playing I still think they win
um but I I do think I think it's big for
them today and I do think it limits
their ceiling the charger ceiling and
the rest of the playoffs uh P Skyler two
things Mike Williams was hit or miss all
year uh also said he's at on charger's
money line so he's telling you I love
that
um also a question of the chat who
scores in Jack's Chargers ooh that's a
good question I mean yeah
I think Keenan
J J Rocha says uh Christian Kirk or Evan
Ingram scoring for the Jags
uh see Evan Ingram's been bald what are
Christian Kirks a little too much
bonuses tied to this game
um yeah
as a Giants fan I'm very out on Evan
Ingram and watching this Renaissance but
I do like uh Josh Palmer stepping up M
diesel says no Mike Williams
I do like that Chargers all in with Greg
but Barberton yeah the TD yeah the TD
might be I used to be a big Trevor
Lawrence anytime touchdown whenever he
was playing his uh College days that was
it Thursday night tonight or Monday
night what is everyone's favorite bet he
caught us for the rest of the weekend
we'll go around the horn can be
tonight's game can be whatever great
start favorite bet for the rest of the
weekend
like the Chargers yeah tonight I got
them on my parlay and I'm rocking with
it nice Ravens plus 10. now well now
it's eight eight and a half so I'm not
and it's back down do we want to we
could just do this you want to do the
Bengals Ravens talk do we want to talk
about what we I don't have it I mean
I've I've let's let's set the stage
let's set the stage for the Ravens
Bengals thing so you have a raven's
future one you absolutely love the
Ravens this week I do and the public is
all over the Bengals I would say most of
this room maybe not all over them but
very much likes the Bengals more than
the Ravens and I would say I would
venture to say most of the people in the
chat probably think
is the most underrated unit in the
entire league in my opinion and they've
done a really really good job of keeping
things keeping pretty much every game
close even when they've kind of
obviously have lost some games because
they can't score right and even last
week they lost by double digits but they
had four turnovers and they also with a
third string quarterback they sat Mark
Andrews they pretty much went vanilla
game plan we're not going to show them
anything because we're going to play
them next week and they out gained and
out moved the ball from the Bengals and
they lost they turned over four times so
I think the Ravens events is really good
I think they keep them in the game
the Ravens probably aren't going to
score enough in the red zone to actually
win the game though I I think it's
possible I I don't completely write them
off like I think everyone else is but I
think if you can get them nine ten
points to me that's my favorite bet of
the week
I have a Bengals future
um and I am completely riding the Ravens
off because they stink uh they don't
stink no no stinky poop
amazing details no no they stink uh and
nobody in the NFL covers a spread like
Joe burrow so the bet that we and me
Giants go off King yeah please nobody
how about this nobody in the AFC covers
okay like Joe burrow good cover uh and
the bet that we made for for those who
tune in every week uh with the show with
uh Greg Sam and I uh was that whoever
loses the cover Ravens or Bengals has to
show up for next week's show with a
straight mustache
um Sam tried to weasel his way out of it
there's just no proof that we made that
bet I there's no it's crazy that I I oh
there's crazy that you don't think I
have a video there's no physical
evidence I really don't remember those
no I really don't okay and I'm in every
show I think I am in every show yeah no
no no no no no we made this at dinner
last night oh okay okay yeah yeah cause
I was gonna say I don't remember
recalling that during a show but if you
guys made it at dinner hey yeah yeah Rob
dog says Ravens money line let's let's
go wow Ravens money what is that what
are they money like oh God don't
convince them I may take
this is I will say this is one of the
more what's the confidence that I've
seen you play I just have no idea and
the other times you've been like this
you've been right so other guys
no this this we're talking about yeah
all right so Greg and I gave our
favorite Ritter what's your favorite bet
of the weekend uh
I'm kind this is the so they just showed
this game up here the Vikings Giants
game I think I'm gonna end up taking the
Giants and I think that that is a pretty
I think everyone is kind of on that just
because everyone agrees if I can't stink
it's it's definitely I just think the
Vikings offensive line is awful and as a
Kirk Cousins MVP better this year he was
not good this year but his offensive
line just set him up for failure
constantly and I don't know if you guys
have heard about uh is it number five on
the New York Giants there's been
absolutely tearing it up lately I think
he's gonna feed and I know the Giants
are not the sexy team to watch but this
is like I this is just typical like we
can just get rid of the Vikings we don't
have to watch any more Vikings football
I'm probably gonna I mean I'm going to
take the points I'm not going to take
Giants money line but I'm gonna I'm
gonna roll with it tomorrow quantitative
research was done this week oh this is
going to be an even odd breakdown no no
it's not
um
quarterbacks starting in the playoffs
for the first time yeah it's the veteran
quarterback who has started the plows
yep I believe
veteran quarterbacks like 84 straight up
and like 68 against the spread but were
any of those quarterbacks Kirk Cousins
I'm not sure and also the game starts at
four Eastern so the sun will be setting
so first half Kirk if you like the
Vikings take it with the first step
right and then take the Giants after
that I tried to get there I try to think
like you know what that line hasn't
moved I'm sure like people are you know
going the other way with the Vikings I
just think that I think the Giant and I
also think the Giants have better
coaching too like I think step up yeah I
think it's even awful yeah Vikings
defense is horrible their offensive line
is terrible the biggest threat is Justin
Jefferson maybe the best player in the
NFL yeah and you can totally change
things but yeah I'm going with the
Giants see I'll I'll jump in here
because uh obviously Giants guy uh and
I'm going to uh apply the emotional
hedge so I'm I'm on the Vikings
um listen I think it's without a doubt
the Giants are the least talented team
in the playoffs right just for my talent
on the roster perspective I agree maybe
one of the least talented teams who ever
make the playoffs which is that's really
uh just a testament to how amazing
uh no I I couldn't be like more excited
for the future with this coaching staff
and we're playing with house money uh
with that being said I think it's going
to be a very close game
um and I know the way the Vikings have
have operated this year it's a pretty
poor offensive line they've just found
ways to somehow be on the lucky side of
these wins but that's also been the
Giants Mo
um uh in recent history and having just
a string of heartbreaking losses it
feels like it will come down to the last
possession and I just think they're
probably going to lose uh in a very
close game but I'm giving myself the
Hedge you know that that's I come out
with a win either way so I feel like
it's a it's not often that you can
position yourself up like yeah are you
saying Vikings money line uh no no no I
will uh I will go biking this poster uh
Vikings Monastery so
have you considered the scenario in
which Giants lose by two
uh
is Caroline gonna be back yet
I don't know I mean I haven't so this is
oh God
we have the Giants lose by too no
because I think
but you haven't you haven't considered
it though there's really no way it
happened Brian do you think like Giants
or Vikings to win by one or two is like
probably like plus 1500 plus 2 000
that's not gonna happen yeah
mhb4 says parlay Giants plus five and a
half and Vikings plus five you choose
five okay you know what I like words
like now the fact that he's just
basically saying No One's Gonna Lose by
five like
[Music]
that is like game changing
touchdown two-point conversion please no
more I'm still scared
because then the Seahawks are going to
score and then go for 200 we really
needed to be up to because I don't think
those score they'll be down I'm talking
to the end of the game like if we're up
seven minutes
I don't hate it though
minus 19 and a half is plus 170. yeah
your wife doesn't mean you everyone wins
everyone's leaving me dude it's over
it's drover
let's go touchdown on this play
come on Brock
give it to him he's right there yeah
he's a little louder now
what's your favorite can you I it's bad
vibes for me to be able to see the live
odds can you click on that
thank you we don't want you to get in
trouble again
because if
the board starts lighting up and it's
like a Seahawks pick six you got two
wins do two two greens I see well I see
you Logan I always do well on these live
streams you know you do big yeah big
crowd that was uh the first one we did
that was me and you big livestream Home
Run Derby you and I Bro Look at Brock
Purdy's numbers that's not come on bro I
need a little Jawan completions
I'm not gonna hit those this is going
over for sure okay I like that I like
that right I like what I like that right
here
[Laughter]
wants to know if you're sweating
is that Kelsey yeah that is Kelsey
Kelsey shout out Kelsey what's up not
yet not yet not yet
territory as Kelsey says any partly she
had that show on the show that's four
times 13 inches this is four down
territory
go quarterback sneaker yeah just sneak
it so we don't have to worry about I
want to win says yo what are Sam's picks
for this weekend soon
Jimmy
The Raven spread first down 10. you got
a little clv
other yeah other takes that like totally
stand away from Bill's fans you and your
quarterback bucks Cowboys I still want
to dive in a little bit more what's up
did Dak hurt himself on the quarterback
sneak before all right Vikings Giants
there's just two teams I don't believe
in America a quarterback sneak like yeah
all right I don't think he says thanks
oh Ryan random fact uh this guy fighting
in UFC right now has the same last name
as you oh really yeah
because you don't find too many riberos
around
how is that not Facebook currently
getting mossed uh Kelsey said she
actually did hit a parlay hey that was
about on brand yeah
I saw that
but I don't like that I don't like it
but Caffrey needs to be outside
I begged
can we throw the ball of a cat for a
couple times uh our food is here is our
uh is he still at two receptions
is someone getting the food for us yeah
I'm handling it he's handling he's
producer Ryan
throw the ball to McCaffrey throw it in
McCaffrey's open oh my God Juwan oh my
God
let's go
[Applause]
yeah when he has that much time
hey Ryan you're long-distance cousin
here is just getting cooked oh he's
getting cooked yeah I'm assuming long
distance yeah a lot of family members
that pop in the chat
I do yeah
they like watching your stuff yeah oh
live rock party is good but
the guy you compared to my homes earlier
you gotta go win this game for me to
really really
shout me out in the chat please tell me
what we want to do because if he loses
I'll tell you again
see that's four yards we'll take I know
that was a good run but I couldn't I
feel like I kind of want to get that
anytime right now you should they're fun
that debow sweat was good we just didn't
I feel like you got to do Sam wait to
break your house for a second break your
eyes don't tell me what any live odds
are okay all right we're good we're good
we're good you don't have to look at
anything I feel like if you're doing
live I feel like you should be betting
on someone who's on the other team you
know like if you're betting at any time
you're betting someone whose team is on
defense right now because otherwise
you're losing a ton of value you guys
thought it was gonna be a blowout this
is going over too so I gotta I gotta hit
something
John Jennings also cannot win this game
it's just oh
Touch Somebody 81. you looking back like
Touch Somebody
oh sheesh
yeah we had it set up 81 didn't touch
nobody that's what happened look it go
go right yeah that was yeah that was
such well set up and he just completely
whiffed
here we go third and seven Boston
Brock's hands I mean at this point this
is what I want
this is such a big play
we're good
oh my God
[Applause]
it's hard he's like say quad as a wife
that references
oh my God I have no idea that is that is
very saquon like
that that was a nice throw by Brock to
kind of Silence
yeah oh but I was supposed to just
emergency
cloud ready to throw hands oh that was
Debo it was a receiving problems five
yards too
I was thinking about doing it as one of
my plays
oh man
imagine that you're basically is he
hurts what happened I need to now do you
like get the catch if he goes like runs
backwards and stuff yeah
oh
that's yeah
we don't rock with that okay
even bird gang doesn't yeah oh no oh
come on 23.
oh imagine that Jonathan Abrams the
worst football player to everybody
that's dirty he's the red hair dude on
the Raiders from last year
this is legitimately one of the worst
football play I could talk for hours
and go on forever his first game ever he
tries to completely do the same thing
all Raiders fans bros
we're getting Brady we're getting ready
he needs a flagrant one no yeah
Pizza producer Ryan
yeah I don't know I don't know who
you're rooting for and what you're doing
you just put the face
let's put the food down you're out of
frame man we gotta Get It Free again oh
we're good we're good we're good come on
we're like so deep in the dead zone
though it's like scary I know we're good
we're so deep in the dead side hey Sam I
know one thing we need a touchdown we
gotta get played we're getting plates
that looks good who chose this place I
did this is terrible right no no it's
it's it's good I'm just messing around
thank you for Content
thank you very much
uh that someone that they want to see
the pizza oh they want to see the pizza
we'll show it they can see that camera
in the middle we gotta go up top cam
good good good good
push push
[Applause]
I think he's still at two receptions
yeah I think so that boy B up there
scarfing one of them things huh
yeah
I'm not not fully cut yeah half this
room is pretty coming over tough for me
ooh this looks good
at the bathroom real quick here we go
sorry it's not not properly cut I you
know I don't take responsibility for
that
this drive is too long Gino pass
attemption the captain has scored two
touchdowns
it was definitely the play
yeah did he break the point it must have
not been that crazy though
that's bull
Rock Party Anytime TV about to happen
you have any timer just first just first
we got to make the two-pointer
wow wait wait wow
wow dude
Jeffrey two plus touchdown better just
got robbed yeah gotta make it maybe it
wasn't oh who left Logan we need drinks
no
if you look
that was a joke
are we not going for two can we get it
like I guess not only
and some Waters
that's a good take
it anybody took Black Friday anytime TD
stuck in first GD
why are we not going for two and also
why are you guys eating all the
pepperoni when you want it plain
wanted what y'all wanted plain pizza and
you just eat the pepperoni
that's the right name
here Robin wait let me back that uh
paper towel right break open the cheese
I'll eat the cheese
I'm done
hey
the defense got to do what they've been
doing all year man if that don't happen
Sam I don't know what they're like I
need that paper towel I need that I
don't know what to say
good man
big napkin guy always overused
and also just don't buy napkins just buy
paper towels yeah
yeah you're looking right in it's
looking right right oh yeah
could use like a water bottle delivery
yeah
water or like soda what is this
oh we got garlic bread
throw that on a plate right here
something wet
yeah
Ranch is this good content just uh
speeding and not talking about the same
thing oh is those wings
oh yeah someone get a Heroes open Bry oh
that's that's the garlic bread okay I
guess it's just Garden there he's
tearing into this
Savages
Max is this good content
use some marinara there you go
so nasty Joe's and hats
bison's asses in every shot
Marana
what is that Bryson Ranch I assume
feels cold yeah oh yeah I was gonna say
we should do like a parlay Chuck and
what they didn't wait did they go for
two or no no we're so dead yeah we're
gonna lose my one we're so dead well we
need Gino to start throwing the ball and
then throw it to lock it and then we'll
be I maybe we need like
we need them to throw the ball bunch of
this drive and not get any like we need
a Geno pick six because if they can get
down a lot and they have to throw we'll
be fine
I gotta hop in the chat and see if my
guy Dylan's telling me what our next
touchdown better is going to be
let's ask the chat flats or drums Flats
bones are boneless don't do bones
boneless you said no uh okay don't put
that once you put that on there the
wings are fire CMC Sam C is on
two receptions
give me that uh where are those places
already has 17 rushing yards sorry
though party yeah
Matt 24 Ray Pizza on Game Day Amen
brother amen
oh man all right here we go we need a
lot of Geno Smith's throat dang he only
got 10 Bryson we're [ __ ] yeah attempts
drino attempts are gonna do us with all
respectfully
we're not looking good with the Geno
play
this is what we need to stop though Sam
that that [ __ ] we'll take that that has
to stop the overcashes on the next score
yep oh yeah
it wasn't the safety
unless it's the safety we need
odd so bad
looking good right now there's one more
store you know Smith 30 Passat tips was
that an alternate
line or was that his actual line
30. throw the ball walking
oh great though oh this game is about to
get out of hand does anyone know the
number of passes DK now has caught are
you
with five
somebody's eight and two on their Best
Bets here no yeah somebody is
I won't say who go nine or so go Niners
I mean do you just pick which bets count
towards the record
he definitely does because if we should
have a Graphic of his Best Bets if it
was eight and two but we don't because
it's it's fraud
um
yeah I got no problem if you guys don't
think I have a clip of every bet I made
I mean
I'm like CBS with these receipts you're
Ryan says you love clip and stuff so
much I mean you can start clip in the
shows that way I'll have to do it
not my job anymore brother
moved down to greener pastures yep
moving up in the well
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my God watch out
oh my God
oh is it just marry not that matters
that we thought they would yeah Seahawks
offensive line is actually playing
pretty well they are both of them got
one side yeah
I'm telling you guys
this car light hits if we can get a Geno
pick six right here
not Bryson that's good vibes
just because Gina will have the ball
longer at least that was a throw attempt
though yeah
he's on 12 right or 13 now is that 13.
uh I think that was 13. it was 10 when
they got the balls yeah that's 13. it
was a big long time out big play yep all
right that's nice that's nice 35 Sam I
didn't know it was that big of a [ __ ]
trash can there we just say I'm just
having him on the cash the cash I'm
gonna go grab some drinks anybody want
something yeah can you scramble a bunch
of them get a bunch of water oh
oh God all right you gotta take the
labels off
or pour them in cups what do you do oh
you're just like yeah
oh drinks coming drinks coming out of
sight Ryan tells me when I'm up yeah I
know come on yeah
these are tiny
I'm out of the shot these are uh I think
these are the smallest Flats I've ever
seen these are can we order the mini
gorilla sweating just the space space
look at that flat all right that's
biggest play dude
um
right down here you guys all deserve
raises thank you guys
appreciate that
shout out to the boys shout out to the
boys and they put me on the finance team
you guys are all getting raises
come on come on throw a pick six right
here man Moody baby with the wild
comment at you bro why are they so far
back
yeah
that was really good is that like uh
surprising you in the chat
sir all right Moody baby has a personal
what personal message for you what do
you say
if I wanted to look at Bryson's um well
he said dipping sauce I joined his only
fans
bet
stop him stop him don't let him keep
pushing all right
there's a really good bantamweight fight
going on back here by the way guys
you got it pulled up yeah
the last dude Lily just starts the hell
out of someone
kind of graphic
oh
this stinks
this is uh holding the game right I hope
that I'm seeing something for your 11
year imagine how much different this
would be if it was 23 14.
little Seahawks field goal Niners
HUD
I mean if they cover regularly I'm I'm
also cool with that I don't oh my God
please please
come on
no way wow that's still he's just saved
six yards there attempt that's huge
big drive for the attempts crew this is
that we could have bumped him out of
field goal range save your under no that
didn't happen
jackham says I need to lock it forwarded
plus so do we man what are we at with
locket right now uh like nothing I got
the stats right here well he just called
his third
twenty okay all right well you know it
feels like more it does it feels like
more are we sure this is worthy we need
to stop here yeah does that sound I need
to guaranteed
look at all that space
there are people talking about he needs
to take his Mariners yeah
that's big that's big
that's big
locket range here I'm not super
comfortable if we just don't get it no
I'm definitely not a missed field goal
or drink any of these no not yet no boy
no I'll just dump mine in my water
bottle so you can take it hey if the
Cowboys win this week could we do
another one of these on their game oh
I'm always down
this is blue cheese
Not ranch I will troll you a huge play
from when I get to New York to when I
leave like 10 yards here would be like
sick you gotta even though I know you
don't want field goals but
oh my God why wow I'm not gonna say what
I should have said I mean response to
that
because that's not a good vibe honestly
why did we not take Dina you're a family
yeah
that was a big Miss wow we took that's
Tyler Lockett and that's a check for me
though hufunga but anyway
it was
[Applause]
[Music]
what we lose
apologize just be better let's go we
have a game to win here
it's over it's over
it's asking about our opinion on teasers
did you do the Bills 49ers and uh
because I figured someone's gonna blow
one of those up I can't do it yeah can't
do it no drinks yeah this game is kind
of flying by
because we're having fun losing money
uh mhb4 oh no who likes the Cowboys I
like Cowboys I don't know no no no no no
no no no no
cowboys I love the cowboy who's losing
the game I like the Cowboys in that game
I said I have them in the Super Bowl you
having the Super Bowl let's smile for my
preseason prediction was Chargers
Cowboys
now the charger I bet on the Cowboys to
win the Super Bowl we gotta keep going
let's check the chat let's see if 140.
Cowboys future yeah
I'm not saying you're not allowed I'm
just saying you're all over the place
I'm just saying I have a decent amount
of money not the thousand dollar dong
play for breakfast I have a question for
you Ryan well you just flexed on me
thank me Ryan
how do I flex on you you say you have a
decent amount of money uh no on on the
49ers to win oh Super Bowl well that's
still flexible but also yes to your
first point right if you get big bulls
and cowboys to the AFC Championship game
are you hedging Bengals Cowboys thieves
oh I like to the to their Championship
Games
Bryson you back here dripping Grease
[Applause]
well no I get I guess what he's saying
is like take one of the teams
are bad vibes these are bad vibes are
incoming in both championships and lost
both somehow can we not just like
I've I just I can't wait to stop
wait so maybe you're right
locket is at 30. 30. you know what we
need we need a Bosa to make a Play Come
On Bosa
[Applause]
or holding
a second
holding let's go wow you can't do that
it's not you can't do that in my opinion
the catch and throat for the parlay my
bad hey we're tracking though we're
tracking everything we're tracking like
Honestly though like the Seahawks
getting stopped here no attempts
that's like a win-win
hell nah
oh my God
[Applause]
we won play without a flag no it's
dropping dimes he's dropping dimes
he like almost got to that man
crazy
pick six is he out the game where is DK
I don't even think he's in the game
unless he's up top that's all we got to
worry about turnover that's all we got
to worry about is details I don't think
it is Jason your end zone turnover
go get him posted
[Applause]
dude they almost didn't see the ball for
like two minutes
does that
wow they finally got to him yes
hey it's both in here in there no
yeah recovery though he got the recovery
let's go let's begin come on Brock down
the field we need seven hey I'll take
eight nine
that was worst case scenario dude how's
UFC are attracted yeah I don't got money
on this one but that's a good fight
we're fine you got nine and a half right
where are they at okay
I thought this was a pay-per-view no no
they're not in Apex though
I'm aware of the situation is
uh Eli Mitchell is still at minus four
yards
love that for you so Eli Mitchell is
minus one yard okay
zero
I try no no I don't know
I'd say about like a six yeah I jumped
from a zero to a six on a one like on
how back
oh you think it's the same same okay
uh probably like a one
maybe make maybe another score
oh my god oh yo amazing
ridiculous
clean up after yourself man I can make
sure I can make some jokes but I ain't
gonna make them show me don't make them
I'm not gonna make them don't make them
hot damn man you would think I lost my
bet man I didn't lose you
uh
damn hold on
I feel like high key though it's going
even
we're in the ball here we go run the
ball not a ball left so much ball left
oh a lot of ball left guys
yeah it's true
that was good for the parlay because we
got the minus two and a half dude
what's up the Cavalry foreign
do you also think that nine to one right
now frame is a little ridiculous yeah
yeah or who DK to score again is nine to
one
which if he scores
and that's how I lose the over under bet
it's getting pretty good too this is
what that's why they need to run
McCaffrey Sam oh my God that's how they
need the right oh my God that's how they
need the room with cat free
Shanahan let's go win this game man
so we can get home
yeah I think so yeah
Ritter has been annihilating the garlic
bread you good you want some more
there's pretty I mean it's kind of weird
it wasn't it's weird yeah it's weird
looking back garlic knots probably
should have been there yeah garlic they
didn't have them no no really it was
garlic bread that's surprising yeah
I like the pizza though good pizza
we'll take it oh my God how's that thing
how's that day
I'm grabbing DK yeah yeah it's just like
that though bro we literally just need
McCaffrey's receptions
Latino's gonna get there if we scored a
touchdown
quarter 12. he's at 18. but they're
going to be down 13. you think he's not
throwing the ball 12 times the fourth
quarter we need to we need to probably
honestly
you're gonna have a driver
at a bare minimum the last Drive the
Seahawks get here if they're down yes
hold on uh I'll get there with you all
right go to the fourth quarter go to the
fourth quarter fourth quarter
fourth quarters
throw your four is up four is in the air
fourth quarter all right
yeah all right
I've been in a worse way
all right so it's not totally dead yeah
if the Niners score Gino's gonna have to
throw he's at what he's at 18 right is
that 18 yeah over okay he's been hitting
locket as of late lockets on 30. he's on
30. that's pretty good I mean the Niners
are already up yeah mine is two and a
half
nine years
still on too I just took DK2 as a as a
hedge on the uh oh we have a live now
two live bets both Ritter and I on DK
Metcalf to score another touchdown nine
to one nine to one
49ers are gonna score here those are the
Vibes that were I love the idea 49ers
are going to start ahead
no kiddle no I you no Debo that's the
only way that points can be scored for
Ritter to lose is that where's the value
where's the value that's the only thing
Ryan I want to know how many value plays
do you actually win
under
it's long term man oh whatever you it's
the get it's it's the get rich plan the
get rich plan yeah I'm normally on team
get rich but with our chats parlays I've
been starting to lean towards team let's
hit them thank you yeah thank you I'm
sorry thank you my personal life on team
got rich remember when Matthew
McConaughey won best actor at the
Academy Awards he was like wacko speech
well he was like people asking who my
hero is and I saved myself 10 years from
now if the get rich parlay doesn't hit
in the moment we can always has everyone
done yeah that's true Greg you're saying
straight up fell down right on camera we
can always say we tried right when the
guy Rich doesn't hit excuse me uh yeah
he cut it but like you can see it watch
he cut it off but like watch when you go
right across the screen here in a second
okay
oh man that's a good cut melee's good
shout out Melly shout out my label
that's me shout out my label that's me
I'm in it with DB I'm in it before Trey
I'm gonna hey guys
[Music]
all right I think we're good juice right
now mate we about to
I think the Niners are back we need
three we need at least three here we
need seven it was just about I know but
I don't know
yeah this is a big play I think yeah
huge play run it here I don't think even
you believe that that the Seahawks were
gonna win no oh I was just about to say
you know who I haven't seen Eli Mitchell
I'm glad he's in the game
Run it here Sam keep that clock moving
Brock make a play on third down if he
doesn't gold goalkeeper we gotta get we
gotta get one more first so we can kick
the field goal at the very least no more
scoring no more scoring ready here oh no
end the game pick he's up he's open
[Applause]
yes
he got touched I think he got touched
that's gotta be that's gotta be the
overall I have any time touchdown hey
you got touched we might not he might
not have been how far was that reception
wait what do you have over 17 and a half
receiving yards oh that's absolutely oh
yeah that was like 30. let's go right
like 40 yards what if they didn't touch
him they did like right here touch let's
go what a cat nice just needed one
touchdown two that's a good bet yes
that's a good bedroom I love it every
time I hear I have I always think of
Uncle Vern dude Sammy
that like locks in odd locks it in
pick that up
he did
a little too risky hey my boy
in the homes all weekend trying to play
like my homes
give me eight
[Music]
[Applause]
whatever
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go baby no let's go
for touchdowns the rest of the way
wow
let's go bro you go get it you go get it
yeah you gonna get it
yes sir what up Brian um not much man I
need a Seahawks field goal then all of a
sudden 11.
okay
yeah 14.
like in theory like any scoring
opportunity would like uh what are we
what's hurting us still okay
we have one McCaffrey
well no the 49ers are going to cover
correct the Geno Smith is going to be
tough because he needs 12. but I can't
imagine they it's probably the McCaffrey
one that is that seems the least likely
because yeah if they're just gonna throw
it a [ __ ] ton yeah yeah
um I could I will say like I could see
the Niners like getting in like second
eight and like running a screenshot one
um
green
look at that oh is that true yeah it hit
uh chat is
uh Stony bones kill just mossed him
uh
uh how's the chat feel about myself
earlier in the week from mhb4 that if he
scores a 50-yard touchdown he'll donate
50k to charity what if he scores a
49-yard touchdown wait who said this
Dawson Knox say if you scored a 50-yard
touchdown he would donate 50k to charity
that's okay is it based on is the
donations
at 12 he should give it 12K yes that's
yeah that's kind of weird hey Ryan like
what's the why yeah I am not I'm not
updating this like you're almost like
trying to get out of the charity at that
point uh yeah I I don't get it how do
you make that green uh I don't know I
haven't heard about doing this I'm sorry
that's all right we just need to do it
the Bell uh
Dawson Knox Purdy's really trying to be
TTS the guy in the chat told us to calm
down he's a second half player yeah
Brock Prairie's out there balling yeah
oh yeah
foreign
yeah smack him smack him
oh
man
stop playing that DK man uh we got a
Teddy Bridgewater in the chat what's
that a fridge water Teddy fridge water
oh which is it that's it
I have to say fridge water okay you
could do fraud water though they could
have done fraud water it is incredibly
impressive that my best bet of Elijah
Mitchell over 38 and a half yards has
minus one yard
but he has 25 yards that is tough that's
I love that all right here's one I don't
love it but you get it
nice oh God
is playing too well imagine being the
guy who windows
can I ask you a question did you bet
anything DK Metcalf related uh I did
actually I had over four and a half I
hadn't heard about it I didn't know that
it was the best bet I didn't know it was
the best bet did you bet it yeah did I
bet it is a bear poop in the woods what
I don't know
um not a big bear guy myself too often
right so I'm prepping an alert for a
while
can't wait
oh my god oh bring it back thanks for
bringing that back whoa whoa that was
kind of dirty looked like a defensive
face mask
yep that's good because now they're
gonna keep throwing you know he's
throwing me they're gonna throw up bring
it bring it back bring it bring it bring
it back back bring it bring it back
bring it bring it bring it back there's
like four penalties in this entire dude
Sam what we got to do we got to stop
them right now and get Gino passing to
22. stop them right now get the ball
back they will throw two more passes to
Christian McCaffrey
whether or not he catches them yeah is
up to us yeah not up to us don't put
that on us that's not up to us I mean
bring it bring it back 11 more passing
attempts which this is 100 every four
four oh false start oh my God
wow
they might be so backed up they're gonna
run it now no not down two touchdowns
it's kind of crazy because I feel like
the Seahawks have actually played like
pretty well pretty well all things
considered
and feel like they've gotten some breaks
to go their way I guess the fumble is a
bat yeah I mean that's tough but
can that time out
Pete this is just clock going man come
on
ah
who is this please don't please triple
down please don't start the clock
Ted fridge water
how's the chat doing
good about locket says Jack Camp yeah
yeah
we'll take those vibes yeah
need a little bit more to go our way is
just Bryson sweating 1K on yeah yeah a
lot agreed nothing too big too they
about to try to go deep
the DK
yep I told you oh boy told y'all wow wow
I told y'all
yeah knew they was gonna try to go deep
he had to stop
that was danger pass interference yeah I
thought it was or he pulled him right
here watch yeah
took his towel off was that what are you
rooting for bro I was just that was that
was a rude
that's an incompletion that's big that
is huge 19 20. yeah I don't like yeah
play two safeties man don't do the one
safety thing two safeties up top
please don't throw the ball backwards go
get them Bosa going back to him what's
the flag that's got to be uh he didn't
push off they lined up oh that's fine
I think it's on Seattle that was weird
ineligible that's true yeah
they're gonna run the balls
100 I just don't know if you can do that
in the playoffs down to two scores but
you're probably right second and 30. wow
to climb that right so who is downfield
16 68 oh 68 yeah
it's if you're past more than one yard
he was two yards up the field
dang
this is that third amount second in a
mile wow
yeah yeah yeah that's big
we're good we're good we're trying one
we're trying it's about to be 22. yeah
let's lock it on the bottom right why
are they not tone it I slack it out the
bottle they did I think we were in 18
were we no no go get them Bosa nice oof
how is that not to lock it
all right hey this is where you come
into play Vince Eli Eli that 30 yards
I'm telling you
I mean I'm telling you they about to run
the ball still minus one so I'll take
anything at this point yeah we need 15
yards for locket as well
I think at this point we're at 22 pass
attempts for Gino I think I feel like
that and locket are actually like fairly
goodable yeah I think it's gonna happen
we just need the ball back twice yeah
and when they're in garbage time they're
gonna I mean I would think that
something goes to lock it there yeah
foreign
but I think I think I'm yeah I'm worried
about just McCaffrey's receptions now
there we go Greg but Kyle Shanahan
Ray Ray Could Fly Don't fumble well Ray
Ray's good bro yeah right are we you see
49ers are gonna throw the ball how many
times have we have to watch Kyle
Shanahan melt down because he sticks to
the run at the end I mean
I think they're gonna because he's too
conservative they might throw but I
think they're gonna throw they're gonna
throw it back they're gonna go to
they're gonna throw the ball sure they
are they might throw so be honest they
might yeah but
I like because my water rip mm-hmm
thank you King
that's two for Bryson I don't blame
events this uh for Bryce is not easy man
there was a point where I was two and
one that was really wow I was that was
only 66 yeah I know those were the dark
days for me
like the rest of your life day I know it
was it was I lost sleep but now I'm back
in the mountain top hitting 80 again the
people are getting rich I'm getting rich
nice yeah it's it's good it's good it's
a good life yeah so seven and two and
two eight and two now because DK I mean
too long TK hit by about like five
receptions yeah I was it was almost over
in the first half it was did that cash I
didn't okay yeah it did yeah yeah I
don't know if we want to take the
spreadsheet so we see the oh yeah let's
do a little scary yeah let's take a
little bit of the spreadsheet yeah
hold on hold on
take a look at this bridge uh oh Ryan's
Ryan's employ inputting on is that his
uh
oh that's Raiders no that's not if we
ever want to take the spreadsheet I
think that's a good idea but uh you know
we'll see but uh yeah there's no reason
to like show off I mean we're all we're
all in this yet Ritter who's your
favorite mask singer judge I only have
one green uh
Robin Thicke yeah I could see that yeah
that that mass singer clip of Kermit the
Frog
coming out of the costume is I don't
know objectively one of the funniest
things I don't know if I've seen that
who is it all-time television clip oh is
it like actually the it's a mass singer
yeah and they're waiting like who is it
you just see these little hands peek
over and they all all the judges go and
then
and then you just lose it that's funny
I've never watched that show but I'm
sure I'm sure if you like that if you're
watching this and you like math singer
you know what I do like Rihanna halftime
show oh yeah noted Mets fan is that true
yeah yes it is pretty sure she's a
LeBron fan I'm pretty sure that's not
baseball I'm pretty sure she's next
that is accurate
there's no way I don't see Rihanna in
Queens
that's not in Queens we don't know that
it's a Mets shirt oh they threw the ball
guys stuff all the time look up Annie
bro oh no is that real you're saying
throw it up great internet photo Anne
Hathaway wearing anything Jersey
Chargers Danny Woodhead
yeah
an amazing picture
is Brock pretty gonna be a Hall of Famer
he might be might be hey youngest
quarterback with two pass touchdowns and
a Russian touchdown Pat Mahomes didn't
do that I'm just saying true I'm just
saying you just want to see you're all
so sad when you bet the Chargers later
yeah
oh is it and what did I say that's oh my
god of course they are oh my God is this
classic how's that Divas
oh
that's it that's finito it's it's a wrap
that's definitely it that's it yeah
McCaffrey yeah what did he what does he
have oh you're right two receptions yeah
oh my God Russia
it always drama is going to be Bryson's
1K which is that's why we're here yeah
that's why we did this oh my God
what a disaster hey Debo nice I ain't go
live we got weapons
give me the Vikings next week man
feed them Niners got weapons Brock Purdy
three touchdowns passing one rushing
touchdown
do I want to sit here on odd for 10 and
a half minutes I know
and it's like what I need is I need
there's no future no field goals for the
Seahawks anymore which is good for me
okay I need the Seahawks to drive they
get stopped stop you can get Niners
would kick a field goal so you could get
55 41 7 right am I doing the math right
no any score is going to put me even
though oh yeah yeah okay
there's too much math here man I know
and betting in general yeah right a
bunch of numbers all day like I said I
need a Seahawks Drive
and I need them to get stopped and then
I need the Niners to just milk the [ __ ]
out of the cloth and like I got a long
drive here and the playoffs down 21 with
like four minutes left I feel like you
might give up like you're not going to
give up but you might give up yeah tough
I need Gino eight passing yards to cash
parlay
you just didn't tell anybody about it's
sick bro it's everyone's minimum like
receiving yards it's pretty pricey
honestly
I love that
dead air
Vibes silent vibes from the Seahawks
corner over here
ah what time's the next so right right
side bad beat situation
I'm not ready to give up on it
Ryan would you consider yourself an
optimist or a pessimist he's a he's a
Mets fan I bet how are you not like it's
100 over he's a season because as as I
consider myself one of the top tier
pessimists of our time yeah I mean zero
percent chance I would like if I were
you I'd be like that's 100 over yeah but
I can't live like that two reasons one
uh we're live in the BR app right now
[Applause]
some of us you know the Vibes can be
dead for 20 minutes and you know we're
okay with that that's not me that's not
who I am you know what I've been here
right I'm I am the man of the people
uh but we gotta chat we all we got to do
also have DK scores here then that makes
up easily for the loss of uh my Seahawks
plus okay
oh the nine to one well but it was next
TD right no it was just any time
understanding anytime okay yeah yeah
okay BK yeah we'll see in the chat
I will say it's tough because they're
gonna need two touchdowns they're not
going to kick a field goal so now the
nine and a half the nine and a half then
looks better than taking the 11 and a
half because this is not a field goal
situation anymore
yeah well
it looks good for a second it did yeah
did the Seahawks played yeah they played
well you know who would have won this
they played great
rights
party is the truth y'all I just want
y'all to understand we are watching
greatness
three passing touchdowns one rushing
touchdown no interceptions
great news that you guys know
interceptions greatness I feel I don't
feel like I said two yeah
I like two how does he just draw he's
the 49ers quarterback
turned it on he's the starting
quarterback oh absolutely starting
quarterback make sure Trey Lance
probably is going to get traded this off
season yeah probably for nothing sure
nothing he's the best he if treylands
came out this year he would be one of
the better quarterbacks coming out this
year Trey Lance you know what could
screw that up though chill out and I if
I were the Niners
let's go
came on that's game if I were the Niners
I would just stick with Brock but I
think Brady is going to want to come you
know eight more pounds
Brock but I think Brady is going to try
this miserable what's up Summer yeah I
don't want Brady yeah I know I know I
was about to leave Mark beat his ass
beat it beat him
I feel like this actually is a good time
service animal or something
yeah
that's how your mind is working there
let me uh number here
and then the question is yeah remember
anything
yeah that would have been yeah
what do we need we need
that's
[Music]
that's a tough tough beat
it's a tough beat
this is in like this is part of the pros
in a season and your record
that's true
49er future
I do I'm pretty happy about this I just
thought this is gonna be a closer game
I was wrong that's why he's close games
oh my God go down go down god dude
that's how you hurt yourself I feel like
all those yards go down I feel like it's
nearing the point of like let's get
these guys stop yeah
John it's actually like Debo who is
coming back from an injury like if the
Niners what was DeVos in here you pull
your starters but wasn't it an ankle hey
I just want y'all to look at Brock
Purdy's uh uh stat line 323 three
passing touchdowns one rushing
touchdowns and a a a rating of course
they're crazy to see him do this as
someone who watched him please you bet
Iowa State so much when he was there you
guys want to laugh eight packs attempts
to go Greg was like pretty gonna pick it
up he ain't doing nothing hey and guess
what he did he picked it up
am I ATD Bryson yeah
you called it in the second half I told
him to lock in yeah
Brock and what did he do
yeah
yeah he locked up in like 350. hey that
was the first day I was 7 years
I need a garbage time DK touchdown you
know what you know what he's gonna be
yeah
I'm ruined I'm ruined then the Seahawks
when they score would go for two because
the score would be at 24. so we're gonna
try and go 8 16 24. so you can't have a
field goal you're right I'm so dead can
we just gain a yard
this is like a Mitchell salt in the
wounds like I've never seen are we at
negative five yards maybe more than that
we're gonna have to close that yeah
but the thing is so late five yards
even if there's a yeah are you just
talking about it with like the stat like
on the screen oh my God okay crashing
out behind it uh what a disaster
and like McCaffrey's out like I'll
probably no he's negative two he's not
walking down out there at all he must
have had a positive play
which again begs the question why
they're still giving the ball to Debo
but yeah yeah no that's a fair fair
point Debo should not be touching there
we go hey
back to you that's what you saw on him
I needed a little bit more of that but
we'll take it
all right it looks oh no
noodle is shaking up
oh my God
yeah no first down guys hear me out
McCaffrey's coming in
first down third and sixth
screenplay I'm not bringing them in in
field goal range up 21 he's done I think
it might be uh that's his name Jordan
Mason time bit
look at him back there 23. he back there
y'all watch this screenplay I know Kyle
Shanahan uh he ran the ball you need a
first bro you did it first go no we're
in The Dead Zone we're almost to the
dead zone right but if he gets stop that
I can't feel like you're 100 over here
dead zone
you have life though if they score a
touchdown do you you uh well if it's
called touchdown we're even which is
good because the like it's the extra
guns if they take a field goal I'm so
dead because the Seahawks will go for
two yeah if there's a field goal here
Bryson has a zero percent chance to win
however they could Seahawks they kick a
field goal themselves
a sad field goal sad very sad field goal
that would be amazing if I hit this off
a very sad fuel sad field goal cash that
would be amazing after what happened the
last time we did one of these streams
with that zero percent zero percent zero
percent oh that was talk about a
throwback that would be good Redemption
yeah or a garbage garbage time
still able to go our way this time
our way
uh bk37 dropped the same game parlay for
tonight oh yeah let's talk about it
Trevor Lawrence
225 plus passing yards Keenan Allen 70
plus receiving yards I like that I like
that Justin Eckler 25 plus receiver
touchdown
etn touchdown we got let Melly cook it's
pretty game scripted what we're planning
on doing with two touchdowns plus 850.
I'm never drinking again
BK is due for one so easy oh yeah is it
Brock party kind of reminds me I love
the I love the uh the Avatar BK that uh
BK have it your way
receptions this year Danny dimes
actually had a really good season
awesome he played very well yeah
constantly improving yeah okay
telling you we get a DeAndre Hopkins I
wonder what they're gonna give him a new
contract this year yeah they'll probably
give him like a three-year three-year
deal 30 ml a year I think they'd be
stupid all right
I'm fine with that I think that that's a
good there's your boy
it's a good Bridge see if he can I mean
Greg you get him some actual half Eli
Mitchell right second half guys I think
we have like the third or most I watched
these words I watch them they used in
the first half and then the second half
to run the ball I mean use our spell
running back yeah
Eli Mitchell but then when we move
forward
and you win and that's that's the right
way to utilize
exactly situational exactly exactly even
fresh
[Music]
this is so bad yeah unbelievable
I don't know how I'd be feeling right
now if I had to even I thought that's
what I've been thinking about like how
am I feeling if I have you be like I'm
gonna win no I still feel like I'd be
like I'm dead if they take a field goal
even it's like it's 99.9 chance zero
percent zero percent chance the odd hits
if they get a field goal here I'd say
zero percent chance on six yeah
unfortunately I thought that was a dime
that was incredible that was a dime
oh
yeah Brock say it with the chest frog
[Music]
oh Brad you need to tell you you need a
tug you need a tug run it boy
yeah
I want to know who he is y'all want to
know who he looked like
[Applause]
okay you put a double he looked like God
damn it that's such a I needed that is
such a good thing I mean I can't believe
he got that ball there yeah I know who
he looked like
he looked like one five from Kansas city
that is such a good throw dude oh wow
God
I don't think he expected it to get to
him I don't think he did either
he was so focused on the feet yeah
oh maybe he'll miss the kick right
well dime all right
yeah excuse me
oh no sucks man
oh no
all right have we deemed it like
mathematically impossible because
they're gonna have to go for two but the
Niners kicking a field goal does that do
anything
is there going to be time for that I
mean like one only chance would be a
touchdown and then listen I I just wait
no it does that would do yeah
immediately yeah
at the 25 or a turnover you have a
chance yo shout out uh Daniel
or uh France oh shout out Legend what
did you see in the chat look at all
these Legends in one room hey there he
is
good to hear from our guy all right
we're gonna get some guys in the chat in
a second
alert is out
all right
all right house is [ __ ]
how's the stick come on
is that yeah yeah no I agree I think
that's exactly right
sorry talking to Max sorry
um no I agree fumble
fumble light them up brewski
rusky what you know about that Sam all
right you know eight yards Gino
eight yards
all right Brian we just sent an alert
out everyone's coming to watch you sweat
this just fired it off on Twitter to hop
in here watch this
good luck bro you want this do you want
to stand back there whatever you want
I'm in room I need room okay you need
room here make sure no no I I need room
bro
I'm too hungover to be sitting down for
this
I apologize if a casa Amigo shot comes
like oh my God that was almost
ineligible man again right yeah
I'm getting that
accept it back them all the way up you
know what's good yeah that's good you're
gonna piss you off a sad punt your
action that was gonna piss me yeah I
just think they sad punt they they
actually they would go for it the
question is
if you got to stop would San Francisco
still kick a field goal oh yes
I don't think they would I don't know I
think they just but I think they they're
definitely gonna go for it like they're
not going to do a sad punt
you can't do that in a playoff game now
my entire life is over
come on come on pick six come on pick
six
pick six
there's Tyler Walk It Out
a little Bobble bobble all right Gino I
need three more yards
you're going in three genome passing for
a parlay or just for a parlay yeah what
are the what's the juice
uh 25 to win it's making me log back in
one sec
people have to catch that right here
Logan you might also got a lot of got a
lot of people in the chat a lot we need
y'all sit we need Gino that's happened
let us know what you think well first of
all let us know what you think of
Bryson's bet in general let us know what
you think about it cashing got a lot of
people here now uh
would you ever bet a thousand dollars on
the game total Vietnam would you ever
bet a thousand dollars on anything oh he
got it I guess is the better question a
thousand dollars on anybody Detroit boy
we need to pick six you talk about
getting rich and you don't want to bet a
thousand dollars on a bet well if I bet
a parlay that's ten to one and I put 100
on it and then is the channel uh Detroit
boy wants to know what he needs what's
the point
pick six yeah well he needs the total I
need a picture
of History also uh Detroit boys
shout out Lions Dan Campbell coach of
the year
so why are we running the ball what are
we doing yeah are they just trying to
get out and not get hurt before they go
to Cancun
oh this is sucks now I need the saddest
what else I see ever uh
um oh Jones Jeweler Jones the Jeweler
said 49ers just got me to day six of my
ten dollar 10K challenge okay I'll let
him know
Detroit boy says that I would cash out
if I was Bryson not an option but good
take good take not an option though
I need like I still like don't get me
wrong they gotta go for two but I think
there's this sliver of hope that they go
I agree Carol's not smart enough to
realize the situation yeah uh and they
bring it I mean you think that'll help I
don't see them any chance it happens but
it's like it was
you need a pick six or that like that's
yeah there is no yeah no situation
really
this game's over yeah oh my God that's
not good either I need the Seahawks to
score now
I need it Tyler Lockett really just
decided to put up a sticker today no
because if you get if they turn over and
downs here the Niners sure they'll run
it but like you could break up it's not
insane and they absolutely are kicking
the extra point uh Detroit boy saying
that the Lions but it's like that's just
this
one
honestly it's kind of tough because they
would have gotten shredded realistic you
got time Gina strip sack strip
Stackhouse
[Laughter]
it's just like interception written all
over it bk37 Pete Carroll is definitely
a questionable decision maker
thanks BK
yeah we got Jack I'm trying to sweat
this same game parlay with us Tyler
Lockett has sold yeah yeah he's upset
about Tyler how many legs did we end up
hitting two out of five
uh we even get to Niners minus two and a
half ayuke and Geno Smith did we hit
Gina Gino's at 27. unless he gets
stopped right here
yeah and so locket might still hit so he
really could fall just in the cafe short
that sucks yeah which was the last thing
we talked about yeah we had rushing
yards first we did
I'm telling you guys right now I can
feel it my bones Pete Carroll not going
for two
because like you said this game is so
over
you gotta believe but like he's got to
go PK ah no that's not Decay that's
tough oh my God
uh Sean bigman y'all doing anything for
the next game
um probably uh crying probably crying
yeah well let's just for the chat let's
just go over a lot of us are on the
Chargers yeah like Chargers do you like
the Chargers is anyone here on
Jacksonville no okay we are on the
Chargers could be our wedding families
it's almost scary we're Justin Herbert
Family in here all along the Chargers
come on yeah
yeah I know I know and if something good
happened but it's like you need to not
be like I am going to win you need to
have it in your mind wait wait wait wait
wait who's on the field for the Seahawks
definitely DK you think so because I
didn't see him
he's Bryson
he's got to be hurt
that's 30. so Gino
fourth and 17.
oh my God oh my God too tight for this
house that would be the saddest field
goal in the history of sports dude but
if they get like if you're just joining
a trap what do you mean Ryan let's still
go for it I need DK to score probably
jumping in Decatur score he's in The
Gamers game it's for the game he's in
the game he's in the game he's in yeah
we have somebody
that's not him Greg he wears 14. oh
that's not him no it's not him it looks
like him I hope he scores
foreign
wants to know my college basketball pick
of the night I don't I'm not betting
college basketball tonight all right
everyone we all have your totally right
for Bryson all right yeah come on Bryson
nothing else matters
chat please root for breakfast
thumbs up for Bryce he's in Ryan he's in
he's about to get double though it's
it's
drover
touchdown extra point they still go
throw it to him
that's not dude kick the field goal oh
oh oh oh we can't have that happen what
about the field goal philo's good Phil
goes good still going down 24. field
goal kick the field goals
we're gonna get a two minute warning
here
oh my God
this is hysterical hey do the right
thing kick the field once in your life
kick the field goal Pete you're known as
making great decisions make one last one
the game's over
the game's over kick the field that's
what I'm saying take the points
Bryson I'm taking a stroll for you
yeah oh out of frame stroll for Bryson
oh God shots got it for Bryson
well Bryson just what's your what's
going through your mind right now not
much man just dishonest honest hope that
you gotta this is the same coach that
threw the ball with Russell Stinson on
the two yard line instead of hand the
ball into Marshawn
like there's a chance to go for building
they go for this genius
that's a great point like I want the
Raiders chucked the ball backwards 20
yards to the other team to give up a
touchdown of the game anything can
happen because that's that's the worst
get the game to 21 right so
[Applause]
that's gonna end me
[Laughter]
three outcomes here pick six field goal
unit comes out
I
said here we go
all right
after this oh my God okay
price in front these are network
commercials
mentally prepare for the worst come on
he cares about NASCAR
Jesus Jesus
they're playing with you Bryson okay
here we go here we go come on NFL get
the game back on
come up flag football right now bro this
is a joke here we go
here to field goal
field goal
one more time
[Music]
tape bro is this a joke this is insane
oh he's been bawling today sorry bro
come on one time one time for Bryce
feeding for Bryson here one
United
pick six
there's no way they kicked the extra
yeah there's something diced up here
there's no way they get the touch maybe
the house sounds like kick bro sorry
oh oh
my God bro okay hear me out
oh a minute and a half bro like don't
get me wrong like you go over two but
like dude the game is so over I'm not
like I can see a world
let's just keep the offense on the field
I I agree again
yeah yeah that's my hope That's My Hope
few more this is why toxic trait is it
better is it like I'm a pessimist but at
the same time like
I I believe in true love man and I I'm a
hopeless romantic
I believe in here man
oh my God XX
strip fumble touchdown
all right come on just run it in
somebody jumping around for a Pitch
Perfect here would be amazing
oh that was like that was that was
joking I thought he was go jumpy let's
be honest this is obsessive all right I
need to drink some water yep
why not run the ball I'm so unwell right
now
you're right you're right about the
whole game yeah oh my God Ryan what's
the chat say if you got stopped right
the time is not a fact Angel see Tony
says I can't believe how fast yeah it's
good um
they're staying on the field walk off
they're walking hold on
they're staying
walk off congratulations thank you no
good [ __ ] good [ __ ] right yeah
I told you he was in
great hedge by you yeah it worked out
told you it was gonna happen there's no
middle ground
[ __ ] damn it
damn
all right
onside coming this is we're back in like
the less than one percent chance but on
time the short onside kick we go three
and out and then they would maybe kick a
50 I mean they're not gonna kick it but
a 50-yard field goal or something like
we need just that's like or a break
break not show but the Seahawks probably
are going to call timeouts they're
probably gonna kneel out yeah do you
probably have to house the on side
I don't know how Justin Jefferson didn't
get 2 000 yards receiving this year he
was bawling yeah yeah well they got shut
down yeah
it didn't matter oh yeah they didn't
play him
yo they're getting a delayed game on the
outside
back them up hey
I wonder if they'll even yeah I guess in
a playoff game even on side anyway but
yeah
it was always even bro
I have to go find that waiter yeah
go live Brock
house here dude is there any chance they
like gain a couple yards and kick a
field goal that's what I'm saying like I
mean no but like and then do it again
you're saying
what if the Seahawks got no way now
game
now you have to but they're probably all
timeouts but maybe you could break them
is there like any kicking record Robbie
Gold could hear 50 seconds left yeah I
think he has the most points that's the
only hope you got it yeah is there any
chance that game seven yards
and it's like a 52-yard and like rob you
go kick it
I mean maybe 0.01 you know what I mean
like it's it's you know very hard it's
not impossible very hesitant to say
straight series well it's gonna be
brutal that's the way like wait dude
here's Mason oh my God come on Mason
this is redemption bro this is
ridiculous get it off go house house
oh my God
[Applause]
timeout timeout they're not cold yeah
we got one more play like oh my God we
got one more potentially one more play
and then it's a Neil
you got one you want one thing about
Jordan Mason he can house something
he runs off isn't he the one that like
got tackled at like the five yard line
yeah that's right if that happens I will
have a heart attack right here
like I'm so serious I'm live streaming
they're kneeling right
probably why are you showing us the
players
yeah sorry
[Music]
oh oh my God one play one time
break one
that's it
I'm sorry
it is what it is you gave it a great run
it is what it is
yeah it is what it is next game
foreign
not that you and I told yourself yeah
yeah wait didn't somebody take the phone
total under yeah they did I think it was
that guy
how's it bro
all right well do we want to show the
final spreadsheet well it's not final
because there's not updated but we want
to show the spreadsheet spreadsheet
um
who did the best
I think it might have been it's like I
don't know how many receptions iuk had
but it seems like Greg had the well yeah
the money line just cashed so minus 460.
congrats Craig great great value yeah
awesome bet uh mccashed
uh
since that didn't happen
did Bosa get a sack no he didn't he did
not yeah Greg finished three and two
um
you know I finished the one and two but
you know the the 11 minutes
best bed hit which like that counts for
two yeah and then I hit a nine to one
line the losers count as a half so
you're finally getting it yeah uh this
is all read it out at the bottom yeah
Vince went over three sorry
um so I'm sorry stop it's that was like
me last time bro
uh Ritter
that's not true I hit the McCaffrey
boost and I hit the DK
levels
the cafe boost is pretty much yeah we
all want on McCaffrey yeah there's the
facts guys DraftKings gave me a ten
dollar Free Bet back
there it is
Logan went I think Kittle missed his
over three and a half perceptions yeah
yeah I think uh yeah I did not yeah two
and then so Gino went over oh oh he went
over yeah
did you know and the parlay hit yes it
did yeah so we lost unlock it and how
close are we unlocked I think we're six
yards away that's crazy
he only had two Targets yeah so let's go
very tough that's tough but I saw it we
saw it again the best bets are now
eating too so it's yeah how tough is it
really so the parlay did it Niners Super
Bowl Niners initially alive dad's still
alive
[Applause]
hey let's get up out of here guys we got
another game to go to
moneyline
Cowboys money line for the BR betting
crew we are out of here Pete peace go
Niners
foreign
foreign